good evening folks
I want to thank you for being here
as we remember the uh
The Life and Legacy of
Mrs EG White
a mother
a daughter
Arch heretic
and Deceiver
on the agenda for tonight
we're going to hear some opening remarks
from
worldwide SDA Church president Ted
Wilson
followed by a long
detail-oriented eulogy
by yours truly
it's an honor and a privilege to be
summoned for such a task
service tonight will be broken up into
three parts
after digging up many of the sources
statements and quotes
but the Seventh-day Adventist Church has
buried
meaning Mrs White's own words
we'll look at a number of Mrs White's
prophecies
as well as a number of her statements
regarding Doctrine and compare that with
the scriptures
after doing so we'll transition to the
burial service
by lowering Mrs White six feet down into
the hole that was left in the ground
from all the sources that we dug up
with that said I want to welcome Ted
Wilson to the stage to share with us a
few important words about
Mrs White
the important role she played
and even continues to play
in the Adventist Church
from the casket
please welcome
Ted Bulls
the wonderful fundamental beliefs that
we have
are found in the word of God
and are augmented by the vital
instructions in the spirit of Prophecy
and with this beautiful foundation in
God's word
and the spirit of Prophecy
we are to Proclaim Christ's love and his
Three Angels messages found in
Revelation 14
we're to believe in God's prophets and
share that God Reveals His secrets to
them as Seventh-Day Adventists We
Believe Ellen G white as a servant of
the Lord and a Prophet this church would
not be where it is without God's special
counsel given through Ellen White this
is precisely why the devil is so intent
on destroying the spirit of Prophecy
that points us back to the holy word of
God
in selected messages Book 2 page 78 we
read the very last deception of Satan
will be the make of none effect the
testimony of the spirit of God
Satan will work ingeniously to unsettle
the confidence of God's Remnant people
in the true testimony he will bring in
spurious Visions to mislead and will
mingle The Faults with the true
just stop there for a minute
that's why you have to know your Bible
that's why you have to be reading the
spirit of Prophecy don't just depend on
Pastor Bachelor or Wilson or anybody
else you need to be sure of what you
understand
because people will try to mix truth
with error
and so discuss people that they will
regard everything that bears the name of
Visions as a species of fanaticism but
honest Souls by contrasting false and
true will be in able to distinguish
between them another quote selected
messages book 1 page 41 gives us another
warning soon every possible effort will
be made to Discount and pervert the
truth of the testimonies of God's spirit
we must have in Readiness the clear
straight messages
those pillars those
Hold the Line truths that since 1846
have been coming to God's people so
today let us here in Granite Bay and all
over the world let us reaffirm the
wonderful gift of the spirit of Prophecy
thank you for that Ted you can head back
to your seat now can we give Ted a round
of applause folks yes yes thank you that
was excellent excellent
we want to thank Pastor Wilson for that
forthright straightforward Crystal Clear
introduction regarding how Mrs White
though she's dead is still alive and
well within the Adventist Church during
the service tonight we also want to
remember the other fact that he
mentioned
the Adventist Church wouldn't be where
it is today
without Mrs White
we also want to take Pastor Wilson up on
his invitation for us to read the spirit
of Prophecy for ourselves and not rely
on others to tell us what it says
we're grateful for the assurance that it
doesn't take a doctoral degree to
understand Mrs White's writings and that
each and every one of us can read and
understand them for ourselves despite
what many Seventh-Day Adventists want to
try and claim
so with that in mind all citations will
be available on the screen for those in
attendance to reference and see for
themselves I encourage you to do so
with that said let's begin looking at
what the SDA Church loves to claim
initially one of their favorite quotes
one of which Ted actually alluded to and
it's found in a series of books that he
was just quoting from selected messages
book three on page 30.
so it says
one second
little heed is given to the Bible
and the Lord has given a lesser light
to lead men and women to the greater
light
so besides this making no sense
Adventists love this passage to say oh
no no no no see Ellen said if if we just
were reading our Bibles we wouldn't even
need her
this makes no sense you don't need a
lesser light to point you to a greater
light that's like shining a flashlight
into the sun
but this is what they'll quote to say
she's not equal with the Bible she
simply points us back to the Bible
so let's take a look at a larger portion
of other statements Mrs White made about
her own writings over her lifetime and
see how they match up with this idea
okay
quote from selected messages book 3 page
30 what what Ted was just quoting from
the Holy Ghost is the author of the
scriptures and of the spirit of Prophecy
these are not to be twisted and turned
to mean what man want them to mean to
carry out man's idea and sentiments to
carry forward man schemes at all hazards
did you catch that
no no no she's not equal with the Bible
just the Holy Spirit authored the Bible
and her writings
folks the Holy Spirit isn't more
authoritative in one place and not as
authoritative in the other
the reason that the scriptures are
authoritative is because of the source
from which the scriptures come which is
God himself
so if her writings are also authored by
the Holy Spirit
they're equally as authoritative
you can play word games you can do
semantics
at the end of the day if the source is
the Holy Spirit
they're equal
another quote is from review and Herald
January 26 1905 10 years before she died
quote
that which I've written is what the Lord
has bitten me to write
I have not been instructed to change
that which I have sent out
the straight line of Truth presented to
me when I was but a girl is just as
clearly presented now
again she wrote that which the Lord told
her to write
meaning it came from God
it's all one straight line of Truth
that was presented to her by God
it's going to be a good night
another quote
selected messages same book book three
page 52.
I have the most precious matter to
reproduce in place before the people in
testimony form
while I am able to do this work the
people must have things to revive past
history that they may see that there is
one straight chain of Truth
without one heretical sentence in that
which I have written I'm going to read
that again
there is one straight chain of Truth
without one heretical sentence in that
which I have written
this I am instructed
is to be a living letter to all in
regard to my faith
one straight chain of truth without one
heretical sentence
remember this we're going to summarize
at the end
we're only at quote four here
and remember these are her own words
it's not the scoffers and the mockers
that are attributing this to her that
she didn't attribute it attribute it to
herself
she attributed this to herself
we're just taking her at her word
another quote
yet now when I send you a testimony of
warning and reproof many of you declare
it to be merely the opinion of sister
White
you have thereby insulted the spirit of
God
you know how the Lord has manifested
himself through the spirit of Prophecy
past present and future have passed
before me I've been shown faces that I'd
never seen
and years afterward I knew them when I
saw them
testimonies for the church Volume 5 page
64.
so that which is found in her
testimonies
another synonym for her writings
oftentimes or it's referring
specifically sometimes two testimonies
for the church
not her mere opinion and by claiming
such you insult the spirit of God
one straight chain of Truth not a single
heretical sentence authored by the Holy
Spirit if you reject it and call it Mrs
White's opinion you're insulting the
spirit of God
buckle up folks
another quote same book Testaments for
the church Volume 5 page 66 a long one
here we've looked at this on the channel
before
if you seek to turn aside the counsel of
God to suit yourselves if you lessen the
confidence of God's people in the
testimonies he has sent them you are
rebelling against God as certainly as
were Korah dathan and abiram
I want to Halt here really quick
this is also what Ted was alluding at
remember in these These Times people are
going to come up against the spirit of
Prophecy it's an attack from Satan
this is that clip by the way folks was
from
uh Doug batchelors I call it the damage
control conference
um the holding the line conference he
clearly was frazzled in that message if
you go listen to it and
um
yeah I wonder why
but this is what he's eluding at the
same thing if you lessen the confidence
of God's people in the testimonies he
sent them you're rebelling against God
as certainly as we're Cora dathan and a
Byram you have their history you know
how stubborn they were in their own
opinions they decided that their
judgment was better than that of Moses
and that Moses was doing great injury to
Israel
those who United with them were so set
in their opinions that notwithstanding
uh the judgments of God in a market
manner destroyed the leaders and the
princes the next morning the survivors
came to Moses and said you have killed
the people of the Lord
we see what fearful deception will come
upon the human mind how hard is it to
convince Souls that have become imbued
with a spirit which is not of God
as Christ Ambassador I would say to you
be careful what positions you take this
is God's work and you must render to him
and account for the manner in which you
treat his message
close quote
again go against her writings and
testimonies you're rebelling against God
as certain as corridathan and the Byram
folks if you don't know the story of
Cora Nathan in the Bible they were
burned up
so be very careful she says on what
position you take regarding her work
because this is God's work and you must
render to him and account for the manner
in which you treat his message
another quote
selected messages
book three page 122.
how many have read carefully Patriarchs
and Prophets great controversy and
Desire of Ages
I have
I wish all to understand that my
confidence in the light that God has
given stands firm because I know that
the holy spirit's power magnified the
truth and made it honorable saying this
is the way walk ye in it
in my books the truth is stated
barricaded by a thus saith the Lord
the Holy Spirit traced these truths upon
my heart and mind as indelibly as the
law was traced by the Finger of God upon
the tables of stone which are now in the
ark to be brought forth in that great
day when sentence will be pronounced
against every evil seducing signs
produced by the father of Lies
close quote
barricaded by a thus saith the Lord
this is quite the rap sheet
and we're only seven quotes well I guess
technically six because that first one
was just a clarifier
we're only six quotes deep and this is
quite the rap sheet
can you imagine saying such a thing
speaking on behalf of the Lord God
Almighty who in his economy had people
put to death one time for doing such
thing falsely a single time a single
time a person does so and is found to be
doing so God had him executed
just as sure as God's as God wrote the
law on the tables of stone he also
traced the truths found in her books on
her heart to give to the world
another quote letters and manuscripts
volume 18 1903
God's voice is to be heard his wisdom is
to guide us we must not be broken up by
any human wisdom or devising God has
outlined his plan in his word and in the
testimonies he has sent to his people
no no no her writings aren't equal with
the Bible they just point to the Bible
even though God traced these truths on
her heart they're barricaded by a thus
saith the Lord the Holy Spirit authored
him no no no they're not equal with the
Bible we just believe the Bible we only
believe the Bible
again she equates her writings the
testimonies with God's word by saying
God's voice is to be heard in both
another quote
testimonies for the church Volume 5 page
217.
the testimonies are unread and
unappreciated God has spoken to you
light has been shining from his word and
from the testimonies
and both have been slighted and
disregarded the result is apparent in
the lack of Purity and devotion and
Earnest Faith Among Us close quote no no
no she taught you only need the Bible
except if you go against her writings
you're going against the spirit of God
and there's been an apparent lack of
Purity and devotion and Earnest faith in
reading the Bible and her writings and
her writings have been unread and
underappreciated but you only need the
Bible right
I mean come on
come on
councils for the church page 92.
I took the precious Bible and surrounded
it with the several testimonies for the
church given for the people of God
I can't imagine imagine saying such a
thing
I took God's word and I actually clothed
it
it was it's good but I've clothed it in
um 15 times the amount of words as are
found in the Bible
I took the precious Bible and surrounded
it with several testimonies for the
church given for the people of God here
said I the cases of nearly all are met
the sins they are to shun are pointed
out the counsel that they desire can be
found here given for other cases
situated similarly to themselves God has
been pleased to give you line upon line
and precept upon precept
close quote yet again
God has given her testimonies
this makes them no different in
Authority than the Bible Adventists you
can say well no no we know the Cannons
closed we're not saying she's in
addition to Canon folks
here that's not the point
the point is what that is a point and
you could argue that but that's not the
point I'm getting hit the point I'm
getting at is the reason scripture is
authoritative is because of the source
that gave it God
that's what makes it authoritative
if God gave Ellen White
all of her all not one heretical
sentence barricaded by thus saith the
Lord uh yeah that's saying your writing
is equal with the Bible
it's coming from the same source
and this is exactly how the SDA Church
sees her notice what she says I took the
precious Bible and surrounded it with
the several testimonies for the church
so for those that don't know you want to
know how this works well we're actually
going to review uh Stephen Bohr uh
either next week or the week after I
can't remember exactly
um and it's going to be a perfect
perfect example for us they believe that
she gives inspired commentary and
details to the Bible such that you can
make sense and connect the dots with
things perfect example is the single
verse in Revelation that talks about war
in heaven very very little is said other
than the fact that war broke out in
heaven oh but man you can get all sorts
of details right now in white you can
get Satan's thoughts you can get things
he said you get all sorts of excess
information
no no no she's not equal with the Bible
she just gives us inspired details that
help us actually understand the Bible
which is why we believe that we have the
spirit of Prophecy and it's the
identifying Mark of the remnant Church
another quote selected messages book 3
page 31.
in the scriptures God has set forth
practical lessons to govern the life and
conduct of all
but though he has given my new part
particulars in regard to our character
conversation and conduct
yet in a large measure his lessons are
disregarded and ignored
besides the instruction in his word the
Lord has given special testimonies to
his people not as a new revelation
yeah okay as we'll see
but that he may set before us the plain
lessons of his word that errors may be
corrected that the right way may be
pointed out that every soul may be
without excuse
again she claims to give inspired
details to correct doctrinal errors so
people are without excuse
in fact
we've also looked at this on the channel
before
but quickly
let's look at what they say in the
statement of confidence in the writings
of Alan G white and you'll see that this
quote is reiterated here as to again how
she functions
so again statement of confidence in the
writings of Ellen G white
we reaffirm our conviction
that her writings are divinely inspired
truly christ-centered and bible-based
rather than replacing the Bible
they uplift the normative character of
scripture and correct inaccurate
interpretations of it derived from
tradition human reason personal
experience and modern culture
Ellen White functions in the Adventist
Church as an inspired interpreter
you'll get Adventists that will tell you
no no no we just view her like a
standard commentator she's no different
than John Calvin or Charles Spurgeon
no no not even close not even close
folks
but that's how she functions
that's called an infallible interpreter
and not new revelation
we're going to do a series
eventually breaking down essentially the
great controversy and going through a
bunch of the pre-earth origin story
which is very similar to Mormonism and
this whole pre-earth narrative they have
but not new revelation
the pre-earth origin story probation the
investigative judgment Health message
wigs causing Madness masturbation leads
to tuberculosis all that's in the Bible
come on
another quote
oh gosh in ancient times God spoke to
Men by the mouth of prophets and
apostles in these days he speaks to them
by the testimonies of his spirit
there was never a Time
when God instructed his people more
earnestly
then he instructs them now concerning
his will and the course that he would
have them pursue
close quote testimonies for the church
volume volume 5. page 661.
folks did you catch that
did you catch the the twisting of the
scriptures there
and who did she replace
well
Hebrews one one and two long ago at many
times and in many ways God spoke to our
fathers by the prophets but in these
last days he's spoken to us by
his son
whom he appointed the heir of all things
through whom also he created the world
Ellen tells us in these days he speaks
to them by the testimonies of his spirit
never a time when God instructed his
people more
think about that the Incarnation God
himself speaking walking the Earth nope
wasn't instructing people as much as he
is now
all the Patriarchs
Abraham
all the prophets of old
never a Time
this is quite the um
quite the quite the sheet we're building
here
another quote rather long and in the
kind of the same vein that Ted was
talking about actually before we read
this
you're going to find a common theme
folks with all of these cult groups
they all have some sort of message and
narrative around now people are going to
come along and they're going to say I'm
not a true Prophet understand that's a
that's a deception of Satan
Mormons do the same thing
the Adventists do the same thing
christadelphians do the same thing they
all do the same thing
it's just a self-fulfilling prophecy you
know before I started my YouTube channel
I said you know a bunch of Adventists
are going to show up and I know that
they're not going to be happy with the
stuff that I'm saying and they're going
to leave rude nasty comments on my
videos and send me nasty emails
must mean I'm a prophet right
like that's a that's terrible reasoning
folks
this is called covering your tracks
quote the enemy is on our track we must
be wide awake on our guard against him
we must put the whole put on the whole
armor of God we must follow the
directions given Through the Bible no no
we must follow the directions given
through the spirit of Prophecy we must
love and obey the truth for this time
no no she said you just need the Bible
you don't even need her writings
whoops
we must love and obey the truth for this
time
again for those that don't know present
truth we're going to be doing videos on
this in the coming months
foundational Concept in adventism this
is their branded version of relative
truth again Mormons have their own
version of this they all have their own
version of well it's the truth for this
day that God has revealed and we're
accountable to the truth of this time
we're going to look at this more in a
little bit continuing
this will save us from accepting strong
delusions God has spoken to us through
his word he has spoken to us through the
testimonies to the church and through
the books that have helped to make plain
our present Duty and the position that
we should now occupy
the warnings that have been given line
upon line precept upon precept should be
heated if we disregard them what excuse
can we offer close quote testimonies for
the church Volume 8 page 298. again
fifth time fourth time
talks of her writings being on par with
scripture God is speaking in both places
and her writings are supposedly present
Truth for this time and one needs them
to be protected from delusions
in order to be protected from delusions
you have to have the spirit of Prophecy
which the average Seventh-day Adventist
hasn't even ever cracked open they'll
proselytize it they'll Cole Porter it
they'll go door-to-door selling it
maybe they've read two chapters of great
controversy
Swan wrote two million words folks
so I'm not kidding 15 times the amount
of words in the Bible probably more than
that math was never my strong suit maybe
somebody in the comments can crank out
the math on that one but
the point being is
good luck getting through all that and
understanding all the present Truth for
this time
another quote
again in the same vein it's Satan's plan
to weaken the faith of God's people in
the testimonies
next follows skepticism in regard to the
vital points of our faith
the pillars of our position
remember those Hold the Line pillars
that Ted mentioned
then doubts as to the holy scriptures
and then the downward march to Perdition
when the testimonies which were once
believed are doubted and given up Satan
knows the deceived one will not stop at
this and he redoubles his efforts till
he launches them into open Rebellion
which becomes incurable and ends in
destruction
Satan is attacking her writings that's
that's
I'm sure just
top of list priorities Satan's attacking
the writings of Ellen G white now Satan
authored the writings of Ellen White
this is why some SDA say I'm of Satan if
he just carouse the comments or peruse
the comments
look at my emails my junk email
they'll say I'm of Satan because of this
but notice rejecting and doubting her
writings will lead to doubting the Bible
and eventually lead you to Perdition
how absurd is this folks
the word of God never returns void it's
the word of God that pierces a person's
heart upon hearing faith comes by
hearing and hearing by the word of God
you don't need this woman's writings
this is utter nonsense
but notice she admits if you reject her
you'll end up rejecting the pillars of
adventism what does that tell you about
the foundation of adventism
only the Bible Adventists
this is insane if you reject her
writings you'll eventually end up in
skepticism doubting the scriptures
entirely
man I've talked with I don't know how
many former Adventists at this point
and ironically it was the Bible that
caused them to give up Ellen White's
writings
totally absurd totally absurd
another quote
it's going to be a long night folks
testimony oh
testimonies for the church volume Five
page 98.
quote I know your Danger
if you lose confidence in the
testimonies you will drift away from
Bible truth same thing
this is the sort of thing a cult leader
says folks
oh if you give up my writings you're
going to fall away
you're gonna end up in Perdition Satan's
Gonna Get You
give me a break
I've been fearful that many would take a
questioning doubting position and in my
distress for your souls I should warn
you how many will heed the warning as
you now hold the testimonies should one
be given crossing your track correcting
your error
or correcting your errors would you feel
it perfect Liberty to accept or reject
any part of the or the whole
that which you will be least inclined to
receive is the very part most needed God
and Satan never work in co-partnership
the testimonies either bear the singing
of God
or that of Satan
the testimonies either bear the Signet
of God
or that of Satan
Adventist this is the standard she set
for herself not miles not answering
adventism not EJ Thunder lorston not
Colleen and Nikki Nikki Stevenson and
Colleen Tinker not Dale ratzlaff not
Steve Daly Ellen White
it's either all of God or all of Satan
that's testimonies for the church Volume
5 page 98.
again if you doubt her testimonies
you're going to drift away from the
Bible you can't know Bible truth apart
from her writings
but that last sentence remember that
another quote
when I went to Colorado I was so
burden-free so she's writing a letter
here
um that then got
well it's from a manuscript but then
it's also been testimonies for the
church Volume 5 page 67.
when I went to Colorado I was so
burdened for you that in my weakness I
wrote many pages to be read at your camp
meeting weak and trembling I arose at
three o'clock in the morning to write to
you God was speaking through clay
referring to herself
you might say that this communication
was only a letter yes it was a letter
but prompted by the spirit of God
to bring before your minds things that
had been shown me
in these letters which I write in the
testimonies I bear I am presenting to
you that which the Lord has presented to
me I do not write one article in the
paper expressing merely my own ideas
they're what God has opened before me in
vision
the precious rays of light shining from
the throne
close quote
so just like before what she writes is
not merely her own opinion it's what God
has shown and told her
another quote
letters and manuscripts volume 21 letter
50 from 1906.
paragraph nine
I'm thankful that the instruction
contained in my books establishes
present Truth for this time there it is
again these books were written under the
demonstration of the Holy Spirit
I praise the Lord with heart and soul
and voice and I pray that he will lead
into all truth those who will be led
I praise him that he has so wonderfully
spared my life up to this time to Bear
the same message upon the important
points of our faith that I have borne
for half a century
close quote
her books writings establish present
Truth for this time
we're going to talk about present truth
some more
um in a little bit but notice too what
she said
they were written under inspiration
demonstration of the Holy Spirit
again equating them with the Bible
another quote letters of manuscripts
volume 20 1905 paragraph five
quote I've written many books and they
have given and they've been given a wide
circulation
of myself I could not have brought out
the truths in these books but the Lord
has given me the help of his holy spirit
these books giving the instruction that
the Lord has given me during the past 60
years contain light from heaven and will
bear the test of Investigation
bear the test of Investigation that's
what we're going to do tonight and we're
only going to scratch the Surface by the
way we don't have two days to go through
all this
she didn't bring out the truths in her
books God did by the Holy Spirit
it wasn't her
her work of 60 years up to that point
another quote
the Bible must be your counselor great
study it excellent and the testimonies
God has given for they never contradict
his word
so they bear the test of investigation
and they never contradict his word and
it's either all of God or all of Satan
we will test this claim
another quote
those who are reproved by the spirit of
God should not rise up against the
humble instrument that's her speaking
about herself
it is God and not in airing mortal
who has spoken to save them from ruin
it is God not an airing mortal who has
spoken to save them from ruin
those who despise the warning will be
left in blindness to become
self-deceived
but those who heed it and zealously go
about the work of separating their sins
from them in order to have the needed
Graces we'll be opening the door of
their hearts that the dear savior may
come in and dwell with them this class
will ever find in Perfect Harmony
with the testimony of the spirit of God
close quote testimonies for the church
volume 3 page 257.
yet again coming up against her writings
is coming up against God himself because
it isn't an airing mortal that's
speaking can you imagine saying such a
thing
I'm sure as Adventists are saying oh if
she's a prophet and God told her this
no she has to pass the test first
I'm not just taking this Hook Line and
sanker
as you're going to see there's a reason
why I'm having this response obviously
but just crazy just like absolutely
insane to say such a thing we're talking
about the Lord God Almighty
claiming the stuff in my books yeah it's
from him
again folks that was a capital offense
in God's economy
this woman would have been stoned with
stones
as such a grandiose claim to make and to
be saying these things over the course
of 60 years
you'll be left in utter blindness and
become self-deceived if you reject her
again this is cult Behavior folks
this is cultic
again claims for writings are in perfect
harmony with God
they bear the test of Investigation they
never contradict the word of God
another quote back to the selected
messages book 3 page 51 quote
the goodness of the Lord to me is very
great I praise His name that my mind is
clear on Bible subjects the spirit of
God works upon my mind and gives me
appropriate words
Not Just Thoughts Adventists the spirit
of God works upon my mind and gives me
appropriate words with which to express
the truth I am also greatly strengthened
when I stand before large congregations
I will not distrust the Lord but will
hang my helpless soul on Christ
close quote
she claimed that God gives her the words
to speak and express when writing and
speaking before congregations
the words for those that don't know the
Adventist Church had to Pivot their
position
after a bombshell of plagiarism came out
from plenary verbal inspiration of the
scriptures to no no thought inspiration
because they had to lower the Bible to
elevate Ellen White in a creative way
but they'll always say no no no it's not
the words it's the thoughts well here
she claims it's the words God gave her
the words
check this out selected messages book
one page 21. it's not the words of the
Bible that are inspired
but the men that were inspired
inspiration acts not on the man's words
or his Expressions but on the man
himself who under the influence of the
Holy Ghost is imbued with thoughts
but the words and thoughts receive the
impress of the individual mind the
Divine mind is diffused the Divine mind
and will is combined with the human mind
and will thus the utterances of the man
are the word of God close quote
folks that is not what uh Thanos does
means
God breathed when Paul tells Timothy
that the scriptures are God breathed the
most literal
understanding of that is exactly that
they're breathed out by God it is God's
words
but she says here the words of the Bible
are inspired but her words apparently
are
that's just one of many quotes by the
way on that
but furthermore she plagiarized
from CE Stowe
specifically in this book selected
messages
book one she plagiarized from CE Stowe's
origin and history of the books of the
Bible both the canonical and the
apocryphal design to show what the Bible
is not what it is and how to use it long
title there but she plagiarized all
sorts of stuff from that book
specifically selected messages pages
19-21 are almost all stolen from Dr
saysbook
the same book that this quote is founded
and as an aside we're going to be diving
into specifically the plagiarism next
month with a special guest
so I'm just going to plug that and
be reminded
another quote
you think individuals have prejudiced my
mind
if I'm in this state I am not fitted to
be entrusted with the work of God
again yes you were Ellen
whether it was CE Stowe or the plethora
of other authors that she was stealing
from
yes they have prejudiced your mind
and she says if I'm in that state if
somebody else influenced my mind I'm not
fitted to be entrusted with the work of
God
but this matter has been brought before
my mind in other cases where individuals
have claimed to have messages for The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church of a
similar character and the word has been
given me believe them not I've not sent
them and yet they ran
close quote selected messages Book 2
page 63. so she claims that no one has
ever influenced her mind
if that were the case she wouldn't be
fit for God's messenger this is
demonstrably false which means she isn't
fit and again we're going to get into
that next month
total bogus man
claims God showed her to not believe
other sdas claiming to be prophets which
is so interesting because depending on
the SDA that you talk to You'll hardly
ever get one that says oh there were no
prophets between uh Ellen White and John
just manifested in Ellen White where's
where's the living Prophet today the
Mormons have a supposed living prophet
and I've had this excessive chain of
that being handed down so they have
someone that's alive well now it's
pivoted as we saw in the Merlin Bert
stream from a couple weeks ago it's now
couched in the writings of Ellen White
there are no other prophets
so really when they're arguing for the
gift of Prophecy AKA Ellen White it's
not just the it's not oh man there's
going to be all sorts of profits but
some you talk to they'll tell you oh no
no no it's in the the lighter rain when
the latter rain is poured out there's
gonna be all sorts of problems okay well
yeah
now for the favorite out of context
quote that sdas love to cite
to claim Ellen White never claimed to be
a prophet I don't know ad nauseum I've
had this commented on my my videos
let's see what this quote actually says
it's very long we're going to read the
whole stanza here we go
during the discourse
I said that I did not claim to be a
prophetess
some were surprised at this statement
and as much is being said in regard to
it
I will make an explanation
others have called me a prophetess but
I've never assumed that title I've not
felt that it was my duty thus to
designate myself those who boldly assume
that they are prophets in this are they
are often a reproach to the cause of
Christ
my work includes much more than this
name signifies
I regard myself as a messenger entrusted
by the Lord with messages for his people
no no she she never claimed to be a
prophet she just claimed to be a a
messenger sent by God who traced truce
upon her heart as indelibly as the
Finger of God with the law on tables of
stone barricaded by thus saith the Lord
I essentially think that she's like John
the Baptist
he was the he was the The Herald before
the first coming Ellen White is the
heralder of of Christ's Second Coming
letters and manuscripts volume 20.
when this work was given me
I begged the Lord
to lay the burden on someone else
the work was so large and Broad and deep
that I feared I could not do it
I've been weak and feeble physically
much of my life but by his holy spirit
the Lord has given me the ability to
perform the work entrusted to me God has
made plain to me the various ways in
which he would use me to carry forward a
special work
just gonna let that simmer that's what I
was mentioning earlier
Visions have been given me with the
promise if you deliver the message
faithfully and endure into the end you
shall eat of the fruit of the tree of
life and drink of the water of the River
of Life close quote letters of
manuscripts volume 20 1905 paragraphs 8
through 11.
she never claimed to be a prophet
because her work entailed more than that
name signifies not because she didn't
think she functioned as one
not to mention what did we hear from the
introduction from our friend Ted
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
believes that she's a prophet you can't
downplay this folks she's supposedly the
identifying Mark of the remnant Church
so if you downplay Ellen being a prophet
then you're downplaying yourself as
being the remnant church not just that
but now you're insulting the spirit of
God
and you're going to end up falling away
from all of the pillars because if you
reject her you're going to reject
adventism
see how that works
but notice what she says here the
highlighted on the screen
Visions have been given me with the
promise so God told her
if you do this
if you deliver the message faithfully
and enduring to the end you'll eat of
the fruit of the tree of life and drink
the water of the River of Life
so she didn't do what she was doing she
wouldn't receive access to Eternity
so Ellen had a unique standard for
ending up in eternity
unbelievable
another quote testimonies to the church
volume 1 page 559.
quote
if necessary I would unhesitatingly
repeat all that I've said I have no
desire to withdraw one sentence that
I've written or spoken
this is of God and must be prosecuted
with a firm yet cautious hand
again her writings are of God
and she has no desire to withdraw one
sentence that she's written or spoken
let's recap here
get this off the screen here
these are her own statements and claims
about her own words and writings
and I want you guys to remember this
before we dive into these next two
sections
she said that the Holy Ghost authored
her writings
she equates her writings with the Bible
by claiming God is speaking through them
and her
her writings contain one straight chain
of Truth never wrote a single heretical
sentence
going against her words is rebelling
against the spirit of God
and going against her words is no
different than Cora dathan in a Byram
who went against God and were burned up
the words in her books are barricaded by
a thus saith the Lord
if you abandon her writings it will lead
to abandoning the Bible and ending up in
perdition
if you reject your writings you'll
become self-deceived
she claims her writings never contradict
the Bible and bear the test of
Investigation
claim that she was never prejudiced by
other people
her words when she would speak and write
are inspired but the words of scripture
aren't
her work includes much more than a
prophet
and she stands by what she's written as
it's from God
remember all of that as we go into this
next section here
now we're going to transition into
looking at a number not all but a number
again we don't have all nights so
we're going to look at a number of her
failed prophecies an Adventist I'll save
you the time the keystrokes the
commenting no we're not looking at any
of these so-called conditional
prophecies
we are looking at full on thus saith the
Lord guaranteed okay
we're going to start with the shut door
for most who do not know
adventism was born out of what was
called The Seven Year Theory
which eventually led to the
investigative judgment and a number of
things but the first seven years
really to the first 10 years to 54 but
specifically 44 to 51
are a key time period
they don't want to talk about that time
period
and as we're about to see
so let's look at this first one this is
in selected messages book one page 74.
she's commenting
well I'll read and then we'll get there
so she's writing a letter here this was
a letter to uh John uh
Laurel the one of the SDA Pioneers she
says quote I hereby testify in the fear
of God that the charges of Miles Grant
of Mrs Burdock and others published in
the crisis are not true
the statements in reference to my course
in 1844 are false so remember this we're
actually going to look at two quotes
here because these are two quotes that
the Adventist Church and Adventist
apologists love to point to to say c c
and you'll see why
with my brother and sisters after the
time passed in 1844 I did believe no
more Sinners would be converted
but I never had a vision that no more
Sinners would be converted
I never had a vision that no more
Sinners would be converted she only
believed it for a short period of time
and am clear and free to State no one
has ever heard me say or has read from
my pens statements which will justify
them in the charges they have made
against me upon this point
close quote
so Adventist apologists the Adventist
Church people over at the white estate
this is one of the quotes they point to
to say see no she never had a vision
about that
she never had a vision saying that the
the door of Mercy was shut to the rest
of the world and the wicked world was
lost she only believed it for a short
period of time but she never had a
vision
and again that was her writing to John
louborough
and this was in 1874 so this is the 1874
quote
she only held this belief for a short
period of time
never had a vision
next quote the other quote that they
love
quote I've never I never have stated or
written that the world was doomed or
Damned
I never have under any circumstances
used this language to anyone however
sinful
I've ever had messages of her proof for
those who used these harsh expressions
this is demonstrably false as we're
about to see but these are the two
quotes that they love
she never she never had a vision about
that she never said that the wicked
world was lost she never had and notice
what she says here I've never under any
circumstances use such language against
those people however sinful they were
actually I've had messages of her proof
for those who use these types of
expressions
okay so remember that never had a vision
about the shut door only believed it for
a short period of time I've never said
that the wicked world was lost
another one that they love for a time
after the disappointment in 1844 I did
hold in common with the Advent body that
the door of Mercy was then forever close
to the world
this position was taken before my first
Vision was given me
it was the light given me of God that
corrected our error and enabled us to
see the true position this is what I was
taught in Adventist schools Ellen
White's first two visions corrected air
they didn't establish error they
believed things and then she was given a
vision to correct the error and correct
course this is the 1883 statement by the
way the other one that they love
but she admits she did hold to the shut
door after 1844 but God gave her her
first Vision to correct that error
so now with that being out there
her own words and her own claims
remember the biblical standard folks
someone claiming to speak on behalf of
God claiming God told me God showed me
and it doesn't come to pass or it's
false
don't believe him
that's God's standard he says don't
believe him
there's multiple places we can go in
scripture Deuteronomy 18 the SDA
fundamental beliefs book includes that
same verse
so let's test this now
we're going to start with the first
Vision this was December 1844.
supposedly
this is from a worded Little Flock page
14 you can also read it in uh early
writings I don't remember exactly the
page but
she says quote while praying at the
family altar the Holy Ghost fell on me
and I seem to be rising higher and
higher far above the Dark World
alright so the Holy Ghost fell on her
she was taken off in vision
I turned to look for the Advent people
in the world but could not find them
when a voice said to me look again and
look a little higher
at this I raised my eyes and saw a
straight and narrow path cast up high
above the world on this path the Advent
people were traveling to the city
which was at the farther end of the path
they had a bright light set up behind
them at the first end of the path which
an angel told me was the Midnight Cry
this light Shone All Along The Path and
gave light to their feet so that so they
may not stumble
and if they kept their eyes fixed on
Jesus who was just before them leading
them to the city they were safe but soon
some grew weary and they said the city
was a great way off and they expected to
have entered it before
then Jesus would encourage them by
raising his glorious right arm and from
his arm came a glorious light
sorry
and from his arm came a glorious light
which waved over the Advent band
and they shouted Hallelujah
others rashly denied the light behind
them
and said that it was not God that had
led them out so far
whoops
the light behind them went out leaving
their feet in perfect darkness and they
stumbled and got their eyes off the mark
and lost sight of Jesus and fell off the
path down in the dark and Wicked World
below it was just as impossible get this
for them to get on the path again and go
to the city as all the Wicked World
which God had rejected
they fell all the way along the path one
after another until we heard the voice
of God like many Waters which gave us
the day and hour of Jesus's coming
the people in the movement when all this
fanaticism was going on early on again
this is in 1844 like two months after
the disappointment she's given this
vision
and all the people who during that
two-month period were like I'm not
buying this anymore went back to their
other churches or you know gave up or
their life is ruined checked into the
insane asylum
seriously not
mocking seriously it destroyed tons of
people's lives
their mental state their sanity gone
those people
fell off the path
into the Wicked World
and it was impossible for them to get
back on the path and go to the city
because they fell into the group that
God had rejected
oh no she never received a vision about
that baloney
there you go
right there that that in and of itself
she contradicts herself she lied she's
not a prophet give me a break
we're only scratching the surface by the
way
again from First Vision
quote soon we heard the voice of God
like many Waters which gave us the day
and hour of Jesus is coming
again
gave us the day and the hour of Jesus is
coming
the living Saints 144 000 in number knew
and understood the voice which is so
funny because their movement at the time
had 150 people
while the wicked thought it was thunder
in an earthquake when God spake the time
God told them the day and the hour
he poured upon us the Holy Spirit and
our faces began to light up and shine
with the glory of God as Moses did when
he came down from Mount Sinai close
quote testimonies for the church volume
1 page 59. she explicitly says God told
them the day and the hour of Jesus's
return no he didn't
and their face shined
like Moses's who saw God
a terrifying experience go and read that
folks take a note go and read the
experience Moses was terrified
but here just nonchalant
our faces were just glowing we were just
and I know Adventists oh it's only a
vision
we're going to look at something a
little bit later that's gonna uh
be important on that but again given the
day and the hour
no
another quote
quote I saw some
looking too far off for the coming of
the Lord
time has continued
on a few years longer than they expected
therefore they think it may continue a
few years more and in this way their
minds are being led from present truth
there it is again
this is supposedly the truth for right
now that we all need to believe
in this way their minds are being led
from present truth out after the world
in these things I saw great danger again
I saw
for if the mind is filled with other
things present truth is shut out
and there's no place in our foreheads
for the Seal of the Living God
the seal is the Sabbath
I saw that the time for Jesus to be in
the most holy place was nearly finished
and that time can last but a very little
longer
is 170 years a little while longer
and what Leisure Time
or and what leisure time we have should
be spent in searching the Bible which is
to judge us in the last days
close quote it's from to those who are
receiving the Seal of the Living God
January 31st 1849 so we're still in the
seven year period
so we moved from 1844
up now to the 1849 period which we're
going to camp out on a little bit here
but again she claimed to be shown that
time can last but a little while longer
and also claims to be shown in vision
that the Seal of God is the Sabbath
this is where they're getting this from
this this
idea and it's being built upon they'll
climb oh no it's from scripture no it's
not
this flies in the face of Ephesians 1 13
4 30 uh Second Corinthians 1 21-22
Second Corinthians 5 5.
it's explicit
it's so interesting to me that the SDA
Church talks about how we just believe
the Bible we just believe the literal
text we're just literalists we just
believe it what it says except for when
you know it says something that
contradicts what you guys teach then all
of a sudden it has to become this big
mental gymnastics and sophistry and
board games
the Bible explicitly says folks now
let's just bring it up
the Bible explicitly says
the Seal of God is the Holy Spirit
explicitly
Ephesians 1 13 in him you also talking
about in Christ us Believers when you
heard the word of Truth The Gospel of
your salvation faith comes by hearing
hearing by the word of God so us
Believers when we heard the word of
Truth The Gospel the power of God unto
salvation and believed in him
faith comes by hearing hearing by the
word of God hearing the gospel preached
believing in Christ were sealed with the
promised Holy Spirit
there it is
sealed with the Holy Spirit
they love to go to Ephesians 4 30. I do
not grieve the holy spirit of God by
whom you were sealed for the day of
redemption see it's the holy spirit that
does the ceiling the holy spirit's not
the seal well no it's both it's both and
he he both he does the ceiling and he is
the seal
and this is because
second Corinthians 1 21-22 and it is God
who establishes us with you in Christ
again we talked about this on the last
live stream this phrase in Christ it is
a salvific term
it is God who establishes us with you in
Christ and has anointed us and who has
put his seal on us and given us his
spirit in our hearts as a guarantee
notice what it says here this the phrase
here that's next to guarantee that
little annotation is talking about the
same Greek word that's used in second
Corinthians 1 22.
or sorry that that's where we're at it's
annotating here the Greek word that's
used for Guarantee excuse me
down payment
we're going to talk about this again in
a second but
oh I forgot to bring up uh five five
well you can go look at that second
Corinthians five five says the same
thing
the holy spirit is the one who does the
ceiling
and is the seal
and it is a down payment a guarantee
think about what a down payment is
when a person hears the gospel believes
the gospel
the Holy Spirit regenerates the person
they are born again
he raises a dead sinner to spiritual
newness of Life they are a new creature
in Christ
second Corinthians 5
16 17.
there's more going on there than just
behavioral modification you're a new
creature the new creation is happening
presently
and when a person hears the gospel and
believes the gospel
they're given the Holy Spirit as a down
payment and a promise and a guarantee of
their salvation
it's that simple
that's the seal
no it's not the Sabbath
you can try and twist things all that
you want
it's not what it says
moving forward
so January 31st 1849 now we're moving to
March 24th 1849.
Sabbath March 24 1849 we had a sweet and
very interesting meeting with the
Brethren at Topsham Maine
the Holy Ghost was poured out upon us
and I was taken off in the spirit of the
city
of the Living God there I was shown
that the Commandments of God
and the testimony of Jesus Christ
relating to the shut door
could not be separated and that the time
for the Commandments of God to shine out
with all their importance
and for God's people
to be tried
on the Sabbath truth was when the door
was opened in the most holy place of the
Heavenly Sanctuary where the ark is
containing the Ten Commandments
the door was not opened until the
mediation of Jesus was finished in the
Holy place of the sanctuary in 1844 then
Jesus rose up and shut the door in the
Holy place and opened the door in the
most holy and passed within the second
Veil
where he now stands by the ark and where
the faith of Israel now reaches
it's from the present truth August 1st
1849.
but she's talking here about
this Vision was given supposedly March
24th 1849.
very clearly says she was shown by God
that the shut door was true
there you go
I was never given a vision
she's either a liar or she has terrible
memory
this was the damage control pivot
cover-up by the way they'll tell you now
well one we we know that one door closed
and we didn't realize at the time but
now we realize that one one door closed
another door opened so the period of
probation was prolonged
but furthermore she contradicts what
scripture uh clearly says
which is predominantly going to come
from the book of Hebrews
but Jesus entered into the presence of
God at his Ascension
not in 1844.
and where is the presence of God let's
Grant the seventh amethyst Church
there's a literal Tabernacle in heaven
it's not just Jesus entering into heaven
itself and that heaven itself is the
most holy place because that's where
God's presence is it's not containing to
an apartment
but let's grant that this is the case
they love to say well what was on Earth
was a scale model of an exact replica of
what's up in heaven okay well where was
God's presence
in the Earthly sanctuary
the 10 the Tabernacle whichever one
the most holy place
so if that's the case the presence of
God was not out in the standard holy
place
but let's look at some of this because
she says that he's standing by the Ark
in the most holy Place doing the work of
investigative judgment still dealing
with sin
still working on Redemption
Hebrews 1 3. talking about Jesus he's
the radiance of the glory of God and the
exact imprint of his nature
and he upholds the universe by the word
of his power after making purification
for sins
he sat down at the right hand of majesty
on high
Jesus is seated folks
Hebrews 6 19-20
we have this as Assurance steadfest
anchor of the Soul a hope that enters
into the inner place behind the curtain
that's that second Veil that she's
mentioning there he didn't enter there
until 1844. where Jesus has gone as a
forerunner on our behalf having become a
high priest Forever After the order of
Melchizedek now Adventists are going to
tell you no no no no no if you go to
Hebrews 9 you'll see that there's two
veils and he entered the first one the
the veil between the courtyard and the
outer apartment no he didn't folks
because the entire Point that he's
getting at here is he's now going to
transition into chapter seven talking
about the melchizedekian priesthood
and what does Hebrews tell us about
Melchizedek
high priest
not just a high priest by the way he was
a priest king which the levitical
priesthood was not
the curtain that Jesus entered in was
the one that only the high priest could
enter behind
that's why you're told having become a
high priest Forever After the order of
Melchizedek the curtain that's here is
the presence of God
period
Hebrews 8 1. now the point in what we're
saying is this is after he just got done
doing this whole comparing contrast
between the melchizedekian priesthood
and the levitical aaronic priesthood and
what makes the melchizedekian priesthood
Superior
and he says now the point that we are
saying is this we have such a high
priest one who is seated at the right
hand of the Throne of the Majesty in
heaven
the reason that the author continually
brings up in this book He's seated he's
seated he's seated is because the
original audience that understood this
or was hearing this
would have seen a stark contrast between
the levitical erotic priest with the
work never being finished they never sat
down
they always were standing because the
work was never finished the work that
took place daily in the Holy place and
then the one time the high priest once a
year on the day of atonement entered in
behind the curtain into the most holy
place on the day of atonement and then
would leave and then come back the
following year repeat over and over and
over and over again he never sat down
but Jesus
by the single sacrifice of himself
presented himself before the father at
his Ascension entering into the presence
of God and sat down on his throne we're
going to look at this more here
Hebrews 9 12. he entered once for all
into the holy places Adventists will
want to say well to hug you no the
presence of God
he entered once for all into the holy
places not by means of the blood of
goats and calves but by the means of his
own blood thus securing an eternal
Redemption
so why am I bringing this up here
because Jesus isn't still working on
Redemption
he's not still dealing with sin
Jesus entered one time into the presence
of God securing an eternal Redemption
for his people he seeded ruling and
reigning as a king priest king from his
throne right now making all of his
enemies a footstool
exactly what we're going to see here for
Christ is entered not into the holy
places made with hands which are a copy
of the true things
but into heaven itself now to appear in
the presence of God on our behalf again
folks where was the presence of God
let's Grant the Adventist Church there
physical Temple up in heaven that Jesus
entered into the holy place where was
the presence of God this is where they
also will go to say see what was on
Earth is a copy
so it's identical to what's up in heaven
it's just the one on Earth was a scale
model the one in Heaven's way more
glorious and what have you
the presence of God was never in the
Holy place so that backfires on you
Hebrews 10 11-13 this is what I was
getting at earlier
and every priest
stands daily at his service
offering repeatedly the same sacrifices
which can never take away sins
so there's the contrast or we're going
to now read the contrast they stand
daily offering sacrifices repeatedly
those sacrifices never take away sins
those are the three points
but when Christ had offered for all time
a single sacrifice he sat down at the
right hand of God waiting from that time
until his enemy should be made a
footstool for his feet
you see the difference
Jesus is not a levitical aaronic priest
up in heaven wearing the levitical
priesthood Garb still dealing with sin
working on Redemption
last one here
therefore Brothers since we have
confidence to enter the holy places by
the blood of Jesus by the New and Living
Way that he opened for us through the
curtain that is through his flesh
the fact that we're able to enter into
the presence of God means that the work
of redemption is completed
if that work was still going on we
wouldn't have access which is what he
actually tells us back in Hebrews 9 8.
that while the levitical aaronic
priesthood work was going on
we didn't have access to God the veil
was still up that's why the veil being
torn was such a significant
um image and representation contrary to
what Ellen White said it represented
it represented the barrier between God
and man being broken because the Gap was
bridged by the person of Jesus Christ
there's actually one verse here I'm
gonna have to bring this up in a
separate tab because it didn't populate
on there but this one is pertinent too
what we were just uh
what we were just talking about
well okay
never mind sorry folks this is the thing
of doing this live
it's glitching on us
let me see if I can do it this way
Hebrews 9 24. Hebrews 9 24 let's just
bring it up uh here on
Bible Hub
she's talking about how Christ
again unlike the levitical aaronic
priests there wasn't a sacrifice taking
place over and over and over and over
again
it says for for then he Christ would
have had to suffer repeatedly since the
foundation of the world but as it is he
has appeared once for all at the end of
the ages to put away sin by the
sacrifice of himself
he's not dealing with sin anymore
sin was put away by the sacrifice of
Christ who entered into the presence of
God at his Ascension sat down on his
throne to rule and reign as a priest
king
making all of his enemies a footstool
and it's at that point that after his
enemies are made a footstool
then he will return
that's why he hasn't returned yet
because his enemies are still being made
a footstool
not because he's doing some
investigative judgment to see who is and
isn't Worthy
of the atoning benefits of his sacrifice
to then apply him to their account and
go through this whole Sanctuary system
that they've put up
again just to reiterate on all that
she very clearly said yet again that she
was shown by God that the shut door was
true
though years later she's going to say no
I never had a vision about that I
believed it but I never had a vision
and you're going to get what the
Adventist Church taught us in Adventist
schools
oh no her first vision and second Vision
they corrected her no her first and
second Vision cemented air
the exact opposite of the claim
on top of all of the contradictions of
scripture that we have right there and
we're not even to that section yet
the next quote
present truth August 1st 1849.
I saw that the present test
on the Sabbath could not come until the
mediation of Jesus in the Holy place was
finished
and he had passed within the second Veil
therefore Christians who fell asleep
before the door was opened in the most
holy place from the Midnight Cry was
finished at the seven month 1844 and had
not kept the true Sabbath now Rest In
Hope for they had not the light and the
test on the Sabbath which we now have
since that door was opened
so she claims to be shown that prior to
this Vision those who rejected their
Midnight Cry were safe because light
hadn't been given through her yet but
now that it has its binding
so again we have two tiers of people in
eternity if all this was true you're
going to have people there for all sorts
of reasons well because I believed this
oh because I believed that oh because I
did this oh I I did what God Said and I
took all these false visions and
plagiarized a bunch of people and
claimed that they were from God and God
told me if I didn't do that I wouldn't
get to eat from the Tree of Life or
drink from the River of Life
no that's not how this works
it's not some present light that she
does this in the great controversy by
the way so if like you read this section
on Luther
I love her her like
historical revisionism
I would like to bring a Lutheran on here
like like Pastor uh just a guy who's
really familiar with Luther like Brian
Wolfmother or even Chris Roseboro over
at fighting for the faith or
um will Whedon will Whedon would be an
excellent one if somebody in the
audience knows I know that there's
lutherans that watch this channel if you
can put me in contact with Will Whedon I
would love to discuss the Martin Luther
chapter of Ellen and actual Luther
because she she does the same thing
there well Luther gave a present truth
as well
the present Truth for that day was soul
scriptura
like what
that's not how people are saved folks
because you believe soul is scriptura I
believe solo scriptura
as long as you're defining that
correctly by the way not the way the
Adventist Church does the Bible and the
Bible alone is our only Creed that's not
Soul scripture
it's all scripture is that the Bible is
the only infallible rule of faith in
practice somebody who says something
like it's not an airing mortal that's
speaking it's God they don't know solo
scripture
so the fact that she would try and claim
but their soul scripture and the
Adventist Church tries to ride the
coattails of that and not passing
but either way
next quote
my accompanying Angel bade me look for
the travail of souls for Sinners or the
the for the travail of soul for Sinners
as used to be I looked but could not see
it for the time for their salvation is
passed
she never had a vision about salvation
being closed off for people
but her accompanying Angel who's
supposed to be a messenger coming from
God and they often times if you listen
to people like Stephen Bohr they'll
often talk about God's hierarchy and his
chain of his government command and he
has like all these angels over different
stuff and he passes the message to this
and then they take it here and then
Ellen takes it to the world it's this
whole hierarchy
my accompanying Angel paid me looked for
the travail of this of souls for Sinners
are used to as used to be I looked but
could not see it for the time for their
salvation is passed
another quote manuscript 3 again 1849
we're still in 1849. this is all during
the seven year period
The Seven Year theory that Joseph Bates
which Ellen claims oh God showed me that
yeah yeah that's correct I didn't see
that in any material again her mind's
never been prejudiced by anybody Bates
was the one that put this Theory forth
and she saw it in a paper
and then conveniently has a vision
oh yeah yeah no I haven't heard this for
anywhere that it must be true because
God showed me that exact same thing
quote about one week since the Lord
showed me in vision
the Lord showed me Envision that houses
and lands will be of no use in the time
of trouble and that in that time they
could not be disposed of I saw that it
was the will of God that the Saints
should cut loose from every encumbrance
dispose of their houses and lands before
the time of trouble comes and thus make
a covenant with God by sacrifice
that's not how covenants work by the way
folks
God is the one who makes the the
Covenant he's the one that cuts the
Covenant
if you don't know that term cutting of
the Covenant is just a
God's covenants in the Bible are based
off of the souser and vassal treaty
model of ancient near Eastern treaties
and it was the suzeran the superior
party
that proposed the Covenant to the vassal
party the subservient party and the
subservient party simply agreed to the
stipulations of the Covenant
you do not go to God and make a covenant
with God
where you're the Susan and God's the
vassal
but nevertheless I saw again I saw they
would sell if they're if they laid their
property on the Altar and earnestly
inquired for Duty God will teach them
when to dispose of these things then
they will be free in the time of trouble
and have no clogs to weigh them down
notice the time of trouble here
is being talked about as though it's
like around the corner
you're gonna need to sell your property
sell your house and people did folks
and when all this stuff didn't happen
this is why they lost their sanity they
didn't Farm their Farms they sold their
Farms this wasn't during the technology
this wasn't like today
you don't Farm
dude you're talking some serious serious
stress
yet here she is telling people
God wants you to sell your property and
give that money to the Adventist effort
the Adventist movement because you're
not going to need that stuff during the
time of trouble
but then she continues
manuscript 3 1849 quote I also saw that
God had not required for all his people
to dispose of their property at the same
time okay so don't do it all at the same
time
we don't want a a lump sum of money just
given to us we want a steady payment
so it needs to be drawn out
but in a time of need he will teach them
if they desired to be taught that is
he'll tell them when to sell and how
much to sell I saw that some had been
required to dispose of their property in
past time to sustain the Advent cause
while he had permitted others to keep
theirs until the time of need then as
the cause needed their duties to sell
so not everyone was required to sell
their possessions at the same time but
eventually would need to and give it to
the Advent cause
meanwhile James and Ellen never did
but they took the money donated from the
cause
to buy their first home and gain wealth
Ellen White was a millionaire by the way
folks
and people like Tom Norris
Ellen White apologists defend this well
she was running a massive conglomerate
you know worldwide movement of course
she needed all this
two million dollar mansion
she had one house that is like 14 rooms
never sold her house never sold her
stuff and gave it away
but she had no problem taking people's
money
they didn't need it for the time of
trouble but she did
shoot the time of trouble did come for
those people I guess she is a prophet
the time of trouble did come for them
because when all this stuff was seen to
be a farce
they were left on the loose to check
into the Cook House
this is sick stuff folks
claiming this is from God
sick sick stuff
Now we move to 1850.
so we're out of 49 now
and if you've given me June 27 1850
my accompanying angel said to me time is
almost finished
170 years later
here we are
time's almost finished though
do you reflect the lovely image of Jesus
as you should
then I was pointed to the Earth and saw
that there would have to be a getting
ready among those who have uh have of
late embraced the third Angel's message
said the angel Get Ready Get Ready Get
Ready
ye will have to die a greater death to
the world
than you have ever yet died
I saw that there was a great work to do
for them and but little time in which to
do it
this again was during the seven year
Theory period
showing that Ellen White did endorse it
through vision
and at this time Bates theory was that
Christ was going to return in 1851 which
is why she sang this she got this from
Joseph Bates and then claimed to have a
vision verifying it which is why she's
saying these things he's coming back in
1851 the time is very short
time's almost finished
and she's sending this out telling
people
we've had a lot longer time to get
prepared you guys don't you better pull
your bootstraps up and get going you
need to adhere to the third Angel's
message you know the second and first
Angels message were already fulfilled
supposedly in the 43 and 44 Midnight Cry
heralding
but now's the time for the Sabbath test
and then when this didn't pan out she
tacks on the health message
which we're going to look at a little
bit
in a little bit but this is where last
generation theology proponents are
getting their idea that not enough
seamlessly perfect people around the
earth which is why the second coming's
been delayed by the way
people like Ted Wilson a few years or I
guess at this point it's been about a
decade probably
I can't remember if it was that San
Antonio or where it was but man he was
just raking Adventists across the coals
the General Session
it's basically telling them Jesus hasn't
returned because of us
there's not enough sinlessly perfect
people so you guys need to get your act
together
basically saying I I didn't think we'd
be at another General Session
you got Mark Finley out there talking
about people contacting him they have
Advent fatigue
and I'm not balking and scoffing at the
idea I hope Jesus returns during the
Stream I'd love for that to be the case
I'm not an imminent return person I hope
I'm wrong but again this idea that oh if
you don't believe in the imminent return
of Christ you're just going to live
lazily it's just so ridiculous man it's
like this this movement sprang up at a
time where post-millennial Puritans had
influenced the region in which they were
in
and had made great strides in societal
reform
and setting up righteous standards and
having an inheritance for your children
not this lunacy of sell all your
possessions completely tank your life
Jesus is coming Jesus is coming yeah
which one is actually producing
the people that were living in light of
Eternity are the ones who were seeking
to further the kingdom of God because
Christ is ruling and reigning right now
and had a farsighted view of God's
kingdom expanding the here the now God
cares about the here and the now
not burying your head in the sand and
just living as though time's gonna end
at any moment yeah it might but in the
meantime get busy
get busy for the kingdom
start equipping the body start taking
the gospel start street preaching start
a Ministry to reach seventh Adventists
or Mormons to Jehovah's Witnesses start
an Interfaith dialogue
start multiplying out your churches
start planting your churches start
running for City Council on influencing
by the by The Godly life and a Godly
character to your community and your
surrounding
care about the right now not just
oh it's all going to end just sell all
your stuff and just give it all to the
Advent movement it's just craziness man
this is a craziness no Jesus's Second
Coming is not delayed because there
aren't enough sinlessly perfect people
and he's just waiting they're in this
Catch-22 as well you'll get people again
these last generation theology
proponents that say oh it's because
they're not enough sinless you know
people yet but then you have some people
then out of the same side of their mouth
well he hasn't finished the
investigative judgment yet
so has he finished it and he's just like
there aren't enough make up your mind
make up your mind
next quote
as I saw again saw as I saw I was shown
what we must be in order to inherit
glory and then saw how much Jesus had
suffered to obtain for us so rich in
inheritance
I prayed that we might be baptized into
Christ's sufferings that we might not
shrink at trials but bear them with the
patience of Joy knowing that Jesus had
suffered that we through his poverty and
sufferings might be made rich
said the angel deny self ye must step
fast some of us have had time to get the
truth and to advance step by step and
every step we have taken has given us
strength to take the next but now time
is almost finished
and we have been years and what we have
been Years Learning they will have to
learn in a few months
June 27 1850 remember he's coming back
October 22nd 1851 you got a few months
to accept the stuff that you have to
believe to be saved
they will also have to unlearn and much
to learn again those who would not
receive the mark of the beast in His
image going to church on Sunday and
keeping the Sabbath being the seal when
the decree Goes Forth must have decision
now to say nay we will not regard the
institution of the Beast close quote
so the mark of the beast was going to be
issued in a few months
she was shown time's almost finished
what they had years to figure out these
people that they're gonna have to figure
it out in a few months
and notice she's she's pivoted again as
well the wicked world's not lost anymore
by this point
which you can do some interesting
digging on that we're not going to get
into that tonight but
as their kids started to get to the
Adventists believe in the age of
accountability Theory
once their kids started to get to the
age of accountability they started to
have second thoughts around some of this
and so now we're getting to that tail
end of this seven year Theory
but again she endorsed this from vision
the end was near
time's almost finished a few months left
another quote
manuscript 11 1850.
we're gonna jump back
a year here
December 25th Christmas 1850 this is a
vision at Paris Maine's Post Theater
house
quote then I saw laodiceans so for those
that don't know they believe that
they're the Church of laodicea
that the Church of Philadelphia was
William Miller and then there the Church
of laodicea and the message is about the
lukewarmness and yada yada we're
actually going to talk about that in our
review of Stephen Bourne a couple weeks
then I saw laodiceans
they will make a mighty effort
will they get the victory one who has
the truth will chase a thousand and two
will put ten thousand to flight they are
coming to to conclusions that bring them
into Close Quarters and they cannot tell
where they be themselves
for they are lost in the foggy terrible
fear that takes hold of them anguish of
spirit will seize them
dare they admit that the door is shut
the sin against the Holy Ghost
get this folks was to ascribe to Satan
what belongs to God or what the Holy
Ghost has done
they said the shut door was of the devil
and now admit it is against their own
lives they shall die the death
I've never had harsh words for anyone no
matter how sinful it was
she just equated people going against
this as blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit
I mean come on
it's right there Adventist
this is insane to claim such a thing
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit it was
the unforgivable sin to go against us
how blasphemous
looking at the pattern follow him for he
is meek and lowly in heart shut your
eyes to everything but the present
saving truth
cult-like close your eyes to anything
that may be saying something to the
contrary
not this is the truth it can withstand
it's the Anvil that can wear out any
hammer
I don't care what you test up or throw
up against it it can withstand anything
no no no shut your eyes to everything
but the present-saving truth
that is crazy
that is every time I read this I'm
always just like dude
wow
there's some crazy people in the world
man crazy people
now get this here we go
this is from her Camden New York Vision
so this is June 21 1851.
this is the final one here by the way
I saw that Jesus prayed for his enemies
but that should not cause us to pray for
the Wicked World whom God has rejected
ah
when he prayed for his enemies there was
hope for them and they could be
benefited and saved by his prayers and
also after he was a mediator in the
outer apartment for the whole world so
the holy place before moving to the most
holy place but now his spirit and
sympathy were withdrawn from the world
and our sympathy must be with Jesus and
must be withdrawn from the ungodly
claim to be shown in Vision that the
Wicked World outside of their little
flock was lost prayers weren't to be
even made for them there was no hope for
them their sympathies were to be
withdrawn because Jesus Jesus's were as
well
oh I've never had harsh words for anyone
no matter how sinful it was I never
claimed to be shown this stuff in vision
she claimed in 1874 like we looked at
I've never stated or written that the
world was doomed or damned never under
any circumstances used this language to
anyone however sinful
bull
there you go it's right there Camden New
York Vision June 21 1851 go look it up
the white estate has this published
this was the final shut door statement
before the seven year period had ended
so at that point obviously they they
finally gave up the nonsense
think about this
I saw that Jesus prayed for his enemies
but that should not cause us to pray for
the Wicked World whom God's rejected
if you read her second Vision manuscript
the ladies listed as sister Durbin we've
gone over this on the channel before
when we did our our test of Ellen White
and we looked at specifically the the
second vision
and only the second vision and went
granular on it
she was upset in that manuscript because
sister Durbin after hearing this message
of the Wicked World being lost
said she didn't like that because she
had a heart for the lost and it made
Ellen upset
you're going against the light that
God's given no we need to give up on
them God's given them over
total craziness man
what is this like strike 15.
it's not even close folks it's not even
close
does not pass the test of a profit at
all
now let's transition to the Miller chart
we've talked about this a little bit on
the show before
Adventist I'm still waiting for one of
you guys to come on here and for us to
discuss this specific topic
I give kudos to the guy who was at least
willing to look at it
some weeks back
but then after this did not want to talk
about this anymore
it's from early writings page 74.
on September 23rd
I've seen that the 1843 chart was
directed by the hand of the Lord
so William Miller made this insane chart
you guys maybe have seen it
had a friend who his roommate and and in
Adventist University had one of these
things it was basically like a mural
like took up the entire wall in the dorm
room this massive massive thing
I've seen that the 1843 short wizard was
directed by the hand of the Lord and
that it should not be altered that the
Figures were as he wanted them that his
hand was over and hit a mistake in some
of the figures so that none could see it
until his hand was removed
did you catch that
William Miller made a chart
second coming of Christ return
1843.
didn't happen shift to 1844. she says
she was shown
1843 chart directed by the hand of the
Lord and that it shouldn't be altered
should not be changed God says
the Figures were as he wanted him
but his hand
was over and hit a mistake in some of
the figures
well why is that I wondered
well if you look at it in the great
controversy
this chart had three iterations by the
way so the figures did change
but great controversy page 373.
God designed to prove which means test
his people his hand covered a mistake in
the Reckoning of the prophetic periods
Adventists did not discover the error
nor was it discovered by the most
learned of their opponents the latter
said your Reckoning in the prophetic
periods is correct some great event is
about to take place but it's not what Mr
Miller predicts it is the conversion of
the world and not the second Advent of
Christ
so the figures changed
but why were they wrong
well because God had his hand over a
figure on the chart because he wanted to
test them
God wanted to test them to see if they
would believe a lie
of him hiding figures
to see if they would believe a lie
to then reveal all the other nonsense
that's snowballed since then
no
Ellen White does not even come close to
passing the test of a prophet folks not
even close
this is me taking her own words
and examining them this is what Ted
Wilson told us to do read them for
yourself you don't need a doctoral
degree to do this every person should be
reading them for themselves don't listen
to Pastor Bachelor don't listen to Ted
Wilson read it for yourself
go look at these quotes yourself folks
and you connect the dots
you tell me if I'm twisting this and
making things up or if I'm pulling stuff
out of context or if I'm I have no clue
what I'm talking about or I'm just
trying to position things a certain way
you check me on this go check my
homework
and I'm telling you if you objectively
do this you're going to find the same
conclusion that thousands of us have
it's not me just making this stuff up
it's not me just having an ax to grind
these are her own words never wrote a
single sentence of heresy
barricaded by a thus saith the Lord
traced upon her heart as indelibly as
the Finger of God traced the law on two
tables of stone
you go against her it's blasphemy
against the Holy Spirit
it's not merely her opinion you've
insulted the spirit of God
this cultic Behavior folks that this is
cultic behavior from somebody saying
something like this
Ellen was a product of her time
the Advent movement made it past what
all these other groups that didn't a
number of them did like Mormonism and
Jehovah's Witnesses those are the ones
we obviously know about today go and
research how many of these types of
movements sprang up around them had it
not been for uh media and printing the
Adventist Church would not have made it
and the bankroll of
Joseph Bates because Ellen White James
uh everyone else basically other than
Bates were kids Ellen was like 16 19.
he was the one funding the operation
so that's why she had a vested interest
and you can read about this Steve Daly
does a great job in his book documenting
this down
about how they were wholly dependent
upon getting Bates on board with things
because they needed the bankroll
which is why Bates and Joe James and
Ellen White were the initial and
original founders
so to recap
she claimed to see Envision that the
wicked world was lost and the door of
Mercy was shut
she only received Vision correcting the
shut door error not supporting it
those that left their movement fell off
the path down into the darkness of the
wicked world that God had rejected
never claimed to see Envision that the
wicked world was lost
yes she did
she was given the day in the hour of
Jesus is coming multiple times
.
49.
50 and 51.
time was only to last but a little while
longer the time of Salvation has passed
the shut door could not be separated
from the Commandments of God in the
faith of Jesus
the Sabbath test couldn't come until
Jesus left the holy place and entered
the most holy place
the door of the most holy Place wasn't
opened until Jesus was finished in the
Holy place in 1844.
Adventists were to sell their properties
and give the Advent movement
the proceeds
yet Ellen and James didn't do this
she said going against the shut door was
akin to blasphemy of the Holy Ghost
and to not pray for the lost as Jesus is
no longer sympathizing with them and
they shouldn't either
is that clear folks
Adventist is that clear enough
please seriously examine these things
all the sources are there at the bottom
of those slides
rewind this jot those down you go check
on these things follow the timeline
if your Fidelity is to the truth
you should be willing to go wherever the
truth leads
regardless of the cost
you guys can say all you want oh you
guys left because you're bitter oh you
had a bad experience I just had an
Adventist pastor's wife tell me that
yesterday on Facebook
I said not at all
that's always the Assumption that's the
messaging the Adventist Church wants to
put out because it can't possibly be
that the theology is wrong not even a a
possibility the idea of that in the
Adventist Church we're at the principium
of Truth we have nothing else to learn
we've got it all figured out we have the
infallible interpreter she connects the
dots in scripture for us for us to have
a perfect straight chain of Truth
it's present Truth for this time that's
the mentality the thought that somebody
leaves over theology not even a
possibility not even a possibility
but no we left because of theological
reasons yep there's probably people out
there who left for emotional reasons
I've met very few former Adventists who
that is the case
they either left and went into
full-blown atheism and skepticism
because they Associated Christianity
falsely with adventism
or
they became a Christian
and realized this is a false church with
a false prophet and a false god and a
false gospel
and I'm going where the truth leads
I know these are harsh words
and I've said this before on this
channel folks this is not the the
kitchen and the the bunker of you know
the camp
this is not the medic 10 of the the
spiritual Battlefield this is trench
warfare
the gash is in our helmet
with cuts on our hands and ripped
clothing we're in the trenches at the
front lines that's that's what this
Avenue is about
the spiritual Battlefield needs all
types of people and God bless them I'm
not dogging on them and I'm not saying
everyone needs to be like I am or take
the same approach I do no
but this is spiritual warfare
and we're in the trenches
so we're gonna say harsh things this is
what I wish somebody would have told me
when I was caught up in this earlier
earlier earlier
and said it this exact same way hey this
is a harsh truth but it's the truth
nonetheless don't shoot the messenger
look at the substance of what's said
so now we're going to move into
biblical contradictions
and errors
we just saw false prophecies
we saw 26 25 whatever it was quotes
early on what she said about her
writings remember all of God or all of
Satan one straight chain of Truth No
heresy
she says letter 106 1907. this is also
in selected messages book 3 page 32.
the Bible must be your counselor study
it and the testimonies God has given for
they never contradict his word
okay so her her writings never
contradict the work we saw that earlier
this is from Patriarchs and Prophets
page 55.
notwithstanding the sophistry of Satan
to the contrary so this is actually her
commenting about uh if I remember in the
timeline correctly she's the fall of Man
has just happened with Adam and Eve and
now she is uh commenting on like after
that
notwithstanding the sophistry of Satan
to the contrary it's always disastrous
to disobey God we must set our hearts to
know what is truth all the lessons which
God has caused to be placed on record in
his word are for our warning and
instruction they are given to us from
they are given to save us from deception
their neglect will result in ruin to
ourselves whatever contradicts God's
word we may be sure proceeds from Satan
so again she says the same thing
she sets up the standard folks of all or
nothing that's not answering adventism
standard
that's her own standard so we're going
to hold her to that okay
as we just saw earlier
the seal is the Sabbath
I saw that the time of Jesus I saw that
the time for Jesus to be in the most
holy place was nearly finished and that
the time can last but very little while
longer and what leisure time we have
should be spent in searching the Bible
which is to judge us in the last days
false the Sabbath is not the seal we
already looked at that
it's not sorry
and no Adventist before you try and
appeal to Ezekiel and exodus no it does
not say the Sabbath is the seal
it doesn't
next quote the door was not opened until
the mediation of Jesus was finished in
the Holy place of the sanctuary in 1844
then Jesus rose up and shut the door in
the Holy place and opened the door of
the most holy and passed within the
second Veil where he now stands by the
ark and where the faith of Israel now
reaches
looked at that earlier
no
Jesus entered into the presence of God
at his Ascension and is seated
in fact
let's look here at uh
so Hebrews 12 2.
looking to Jesus the founder and
Perfecter of our faith who for the joy
that was set before him endured the
cross despising the shame and is seated
at the right hand of the Throne of God
again the author tells you he seated
it's like the fifth time in the book
he's told you this
and it's not just
being said it's being said for a very
specific reason
Romans 8 34 who is to condemn Christ
Jesus is the one who died more than that
who was raised who's at the right hand
of God who indeed is interceding for us
again where is God
if we roll with this it's identical
what's in heaven of what's what was on
Earth or what's on Earth is identical to
what was in heaven
okay God's presence was never in the
Holy place it's always in the most holy
Place only there's no throne in the Holy
place there wasn't even a throne I mean
I know The Mercy Seat was obviously on
top of the Ark of the Covenant but
no
Colossians 3 1.
if then you've been raised with Christ
seek the things that are above where
Christ is seated at the right hand of
God
he's not standing next to the ark
dealing with sin I mean this is just
replete the Old Testament even Prophet
the psalmist prophesied about this it's
like
no it's just it's not it's not true
next quote
two years ago I came to the conclusion
that there was danger in using the Flesh
of dead animals
and since then I have not used meat at
all
this is part of their health message for
those that don't know you got to be a
vegetarian preferably vegan and you're
about to see why
it's never placed on my table
I use fish when I can get it
we can get beautiful fish from the
saltwater lake near here
I use neither teen or coffee as I labor
against these things I cannot but
practice that which I know to be best
for health and my family are all in
perfect harmony with me
so apparently fish
aren't flesh foods of dead animals
there's danger in using the Flesh of
dead animals and since that and since
that's the case
I've not used meat at all it's never
placed on my table I eat fish when I can
get it
okay it's just like what
again more about the health message this
is why you have to be vegetarian or
vegan eventually this got attacked onto
this third Angel's message by the way
which is why most people know about
Adventists that they keep the Sabbath
supposedly and
they're vegetarians because those are
the two things that are part of this
final third Angel's message well then we
get into the fourth Angels message
supposedly of later on in Revelation but
she says quote this testimony for the
church volume 3 page 162.
this is 1872. so before 1876 she's
eating fish
she was also eating other stuff beef tea
and Venison and she's writing letters to
her son Willie saying oh yeah we had
great we love venison but it's it's
pretty expensive and pretty pricey so we
try to uh eat other things
but 1876 Meats never found on my table
because
um
I haven't used meat at all even though
I'm eating fish
the Apostle Paul exhorts the church I
beseech you therefore Brethren by the
mercies of God that ye present your
bodies a Living Sacrifice wholly
acceptable unto God which is your
reasonable service AKA Paul was saying
you need to be a vegetarian
no
men then can make their bodies Unholy by
sinful indulgences
if Unholy they are unfitted to be
spiritual worshipers and are not worthy
of Heaven if man will cherish the light
that God in Mercy gives him upon Health
reform he may be Sanctified through the
truth and fitted for immortality
but if he disregards that light and
lives in violation of natural law he
must pay the penalty
so this was said four years prior
yet she was eating meat herself meaning
she wasn't fit for immortality because
part of this health reform message is
that you can't be eaten the flesh food
of dead animals
I mean
her writings are replete with stuff like
this if you just look at the dates and
the timeline of these things
this woman is not practicing what she
preaches yet I don't have that quote in
here tonight
but she straight up says I do not do one
thing and practice another
okay
sure
quote
the Bible know where sanctions the use
of intoxicating wine the wine that
Christ made from water at the marriage
Feast of Cana was the pure juice of the
grape this is the new wine found in the
cluster
of which the scriptures say destroy it
not for a blessing is in it Isaiah 65 8.
uh no false this is very easy to debunk
the Greek word for wine that's used in
John 2 go look it up it's oinos
o-i-n-o-s
the standard Greek word for fermented
alcoholic wine which is also used in
Ephesians 5 where Paul says to not be
drunk on it
it's not grape juice
this idea that the fruit of the vine the
new the new wine is non-fermented as if
grapes are automatically fermented when
grown and now there's like a new one
it's not what
but furthermore Adventists love the Book
of Ecclesiastes
they love it when they're talking about
the state of the dead the dead know
nothing
it's just what it says so therefore that
just is talking about the afterlife and
there we go you know you just take it
how it is okay Ecclesiastes 9 7
Adventists talking about grape juice
go eat your bread with joy and drink
your wine with a merry heart for God has
already approved what you do
okay so if we're going to take
Ecclesiastes that way where it's just
all prescriptive it's just whatever it
says it's just that's just telling us
how it is there you go God says to go
eat your bread with joy and drink your
wine with a merry heart for God has
already approved of what you do or Psalm
104 14-15
you caused the grass to grow for the
livestock and plants for man to
cultivate that he may bring forth food
from the earth and wine to Glad in the
heart of man oil to make his face shine
and bread to strengthen man's heart
no the wine in in the wedding miracle
was alcoholic fermented wine
and if you read the story and notice
some of the details as well
you'll also know why this is the case
because when
the host comes to
figure out what the heck is going on
with this wine
he takes it
and it's better
they ran out of wine so then Jesus turns
water into wine which is also somewhat a
typology of of number of things
regarding water and
not going to get into all that but
the host says this Wine's better than
the wine that we've already given out
no one saves the better wine for later
the better wine is always given first
that way when everyone's a little bit
their taste you know buds are a little
bit more loosened and they're a little
more relaxed
the less good wine isn't as bad
Jesus did the opposite
furthermore the Lord's Supper is
supposed to be done with wine I
understand there's lots of churches that
do it with grape juice but
the Lord's Supper I know they haven't
shirt yourself to say no no Jesus's
blood is is pure it's unfermented and so
fermentation is supposed to mean the
Wine's not pure and so since it's
supposed to be well in their view they
don't believe it's the blood of Christ
but symbolic of the blood of Christ his
blood is pure which means it's
unfermented these sorts of just
again elenisms adventisms that get tied
into the stuff that Ellen White says so
that's the inspired detail there so
that's where they're getting this from
no the wine was was actual alcoholic
wine folks
another quote same book Ministry of
healing page 320 and 321.
the diet reform should be Progressive as
disease and animals increases the use of
milk and eggs will become more and more
unsafe an effort should be made to
supply their place with other things
that are healthful and inexpensive the
people everywhere should be taught how
to cook without milk and eggs so far as
possible and yet have their food
wholesome and palatable this is false
100 false so easily verifiable
here we go this is from the American
Dairy farming associate the American
Dairy Association history of dairy
farming
humans have been drinking milk from cows
for thousands of years modern Dairy
farming began in the early 1900s
interesting so right around the time of
Ellen writing these things and right
around the time that she died
modern Dairy farming began in the early
1900s after pasteurization was developed
and utilized widely
pasteurization allows for a safer
product
and extends milk's shelf life by
eradicating spoilage causing bacteria
through the application of heat this
process allows milk to last longer and
be shipped further
so right after Ellen dies the process of
pasteurization becomes developed and
dairy products become safer
what's the excuse on this one Adventist
oh it was conditional it was conditional
upon something in the environment habit
I can already hear it
give it up folks get give it up at this
point it's just like we're just
I mean the coffin that we're about to
lower into the ground has like
500 Nails in it at this point
manuscript 33 1897.
the present truth the special message
given to our world that's their message
by the way so for those that don't know
the Adventist Church thinks their
special place in the Christian world is
that God's given them a special message
to take to everybody else again one of
the Hallmark signs of a cult we have a
special message from God that no one
else has we're here to reveal it to you
it was uniquely given to us
the present truth the special message
given to our world even the third
Angel's message comprehends a vast field
containing Heavenly Treasures no one can
be excusable who says I will no longer
have anything to do with these Special
messages I will preach Christ
no one can preach Christ and present the
truth as it is in Jesus unless he
presents the truths that are to come
before the people at the present time
when such important developments are
taking place
you can't preach Christ without
proclaiming the supposed special message
given to the SDA Church through Ellen
absurd absurd is that how the Apostle is
that how Paul the Apostle taught the
gospel it's an ever-evolving present
truth message that changes in morphs
over time based on new information God
gives through prophets outside of
scripture when the Canon is closed
furthermore what does Paul say in First
Corinthians 2 1-2
and I Brethren when I came to you did
not come with Excellence of speech or of
wisdom declaring to uh to you the
testimony of God for I determined not to
know anything among you except Jesus
Christ and him crucified
what was the focus of Paul's teaching
preaching and Ministry
among the Corinthians
the core Crux of it all Jesus Christ and
him crucified
not the supposed third Angel's message
of The Seventh-Day Sabbath and being the
seal and the health message
of which Alan claimed is the third met
like I said is the third Angel's message
and Verity
his point was that in all of his
teaching in all of his preaching in all
of his missionary work the central point
of importance was the cross
he's essentially saying you might forget
other things that I've taught you it's
just like how we have like exaggerations
oh I'm so hungry I could eat a camel
he's not saying the only thing you know
the only single thing I've ever told you
no no he's dra he's making a drastic
point he's essentially saying you might
forget other things that I've taught you
but do not forget the cross because it
was on the cross through the cross and
by the cross that Jesus performed his
work of redemption
but according to Ellen that's not good
enough
you have to tack on the unique Adventist
message
that God supposedly only gave them as a
special mission to take to the rest of
the world
this whole idea of present truth is the
issue the truth is not present like that
meaning it doesn't morph and change and
become something unique for a certain
period of time Jesus is the truth I am
the way the truth and the life
he's the same yesterday today and
forever Hebrews 13 8.
he's immutable
the truth is objective and definite
transcends all generations
again Jesus is the truth
Hebrews 13 8 Jesus Christ is the same
today yesterday and forever
the truth does not change like that
folks oh it's a special message with
special light for this time that people
are now accountable to because it's been
revealed
through God's messenger
the next one
Michael or Christ talking about Michael
the Archangel with the angels that
buried Moses
came down from heaven after he'd
remained in the grave for a short time
and resurrected him and took him to
heaven the Ministry of Health page 333.
or sorry that's the the note on the
slide there is is incorrect that should
have been copied over it's actually
spiritual gifts volume 4A page 57.
the Bible does not say this
this is again where these inspired
details that no new revelation except
for the fact that Michael the Archangel
who is another name in their view for
Jesus they don't believe the same thing
as the Jehovah's Witnesses that he's a
created angel and
yada yada they say it's just an
alternative name for for Jesus
but no Michael did not resurrect Moses
because Jesus is the first fruits of the
Resurrection
the first resurrection of the new
creation if Moses was resurrected that
would mean that Moses was had to have
been resurrected into a glorified body
to be able to go to heaven
no
Jesus is the firstfruits of the
Resurrection First Corinthians 15 20-23
furthermore John 3 13 says no one has
ascended to heaven
but also
in Matthew 17 9
because what's being discussed here
is regarding the Transfiguration
and Moses came down and
Jesus explicitly says that the
Transfiguration was a vision
not a physical literal presence of Moses
and Elijah
Adventists always want to assure us that
Ellen White's Visions they weren't real
or physical
they weren't like tangible physical it
was just a vision
yet here they'll take the
Transfiguration literally
it was a vision folks Matthew 17 9 Jesus
specifically says tell no one of the
vision that you saw
Moses and Elijah were in the upper
compartment of Abraham's bosom Paradise
not heaven
but furthermore again the Bible does not
say that Michael the Archangel
resurrected Moses and took him to heaven
this is an area where they'll point to
it says see the text it says that there
was a dispute over Moses's body
right but it doesn't say anything about
being resurrected and taken to Heaven by
Michael the Archangel this is where
you're now supposed to be filling in the
gaps with these inspired details
it doesn't contradict the Bible right it
just adds on to the Bible and just feels
I could go along and just start filling
in gaps all over the place and say God
showed me this
yeah no
Spirit of Prophecy volume 1 page 22.
all the Heavenly hosts were summoned to
appear before the father
to have each case determined Satan
unblushingly made known his
dissatisfaction that Christ should be
preferred before him he stood up proudly
and urged that he should be equal with
God and should be taken into conference
with the father and understand his
purposes God informed Satan that his son
alone he would reveal his secret
purposes
and he required all the family in heaven
even Satan to yield him implicit
unquestioned obedience but that he
talking about Satan had proved himself
unworthy a place in heaven
that means Jesus was not co-equal with
the father from eternity past he had
knowledge and information revealed to
him by the father
Jesus is all-knowing Jesus knows all
things
John 2 23-25 John 16 29-31 21 well let's
just look at these
Jesus knows all things
we'll talk about at some point later on
him not knowing the day or the hour
because that's what everybody wants to
go to well he didn't know the day or the
hour yeah well we're not looking at that
tonight but we are going to look at this
and you're going to clearly see
now when he was in Jerusalem at the
Passover feast talking about Jesus many
believed in his name when they saw the
signs that he was doing but Jesus on his
part did not entrust himself to them
because he knew all people and needed no
one to Bear witness about man for he
himself knew what was in man
well that doesn't say he knows all
things okay well let's keep again we're
just gonna do a systematic look at these
John 16 29-31 his disciples said ah this
is after Jesus has said a parable
and then he's talking to the disciples
privately
and his disciples said ah now you're
speaking plainly and not using
figurative speech
now we know that you know all things
and do not need anyone to question you
this is why we believe that you came
from God Jesus answered them do you now
believe
they say oh wow Jesus now that you're
not speaking figuratively we realize you
know all things
Jesus doesn't correct them
John 21 17.
he said to them a third time
Simon son of John
whoops
sorry folks get that up there for you
he said to him the third time Simon son
of John do you love me Peter was grieved
because he said to him the third time do
you love me and he said to him Lord you
know everything you know that I love you
Jesus said to him feed my sheep
you know everything
furthermore First John 3 20 for whenever
our heart condemns us God is greater
than our heart and he knows everything
so there you go Jesus Is God he knows
all things
first John here tells us God Alone knows
Jesus did not
have some secret Knowledge from the
father given to him at a certain point
prior to the creation of the Earth
in some secret purposes that were
revealed to him that then made Lucifer
become jealous
but furthermore where did the holy
spirit's involvement in all this oh
right this is at a time where again not
one heretical sentence
all came from God they didn't believe
the Holy Spirit was a person at this
point
it was the presence of the father and
the son in their physical absence of
being somewhere
always the Holy Spirit and Jesus always
getting demoted
another quote Spirit of Prophecy volume
1 page 45
sorrow filled Heaven as it was realized
that man was lost
and the world that God created was to be
filled with Mortals doomed to misery
sickness and death and there was no way
of Escape for the offender talking about
Adam and Eve after the fall
the whole family of Adam must die I saw
I saw I saw the lovely Jesus and beheld
an expression of sympathy and sorrow
upon his countenance soon I saw him
approach the exceeding Bright Light
which enshrouded the father said my
accompanying angel
he is in close converse with the father
the anxiety the Angels seem to be
intense while Jesus was communing with
his father
three times he was shut in by the
Glorious light about the father and the
third time he came from the father his
person could be seen
she couldn't hold the father
too much Glory
but Jesus
in all of his glory
Cakewalk
always demoting Christ
his countenance was calm free from all
perplexity and trouble and shown with
benevolence and loveliness such as words
cannot express he then made known to the
Angelic host that a way of Escape had
been made for lost man
he told them that he had been pleading
with his father
and had offered to give his life a
ransom and take the sentence of death
upon himself that through him man might
find pardon
that through the merits of his blood and
obedience to the law of God they could
have favor with God
and be brought into the beautiful garden
and eat of the fruit of the Tree of Life
this is division in the godhead folks
the father had to be convinced of a plan
that Jesus had that the father wasn't
aware of
Jesus is the lamb slain from the
foundation
there's no convincing going on back and
forth between the father and the son
this goes to show that Adventists have
a very strange
Dynamic of what they would call the
godhead
there's no revealing of knowledge to
this person
that's then to this person
like the father to Jesus and then the
Jesus to the Holy Spirit or anything
like that father son and spirit are the
one Lord God Almighty
they're co-equal co-eternal all-knowing
they have different roles
there's difference on that level What's
called the economic Trinity it's not the
father that incarnated it's not the holy
spirit that incarnated it's the son
but the father son and the spirit are
co-equal co-eternal
but furthermore
Ellen White and the SDA SDA theologians
claim that the Oneness of their Heavenly
Trio is in Mission purpose and character
yet here we see them at Cross purposes
if you ask the Adventist Church well
what makes them one it's their mission
their purpose their character we've
looked at this lots of times on the
channel
okay well in the mission the father had
to be convinced of a plan that he didn't
know that the sun had and after it took
three times to convince him
hello
yeah
Ellen White Ministry of healing page 422
here's what she says the unity that
exists between Christ and his disciples
does not destroy the personality of
either we've looked at how they Define
person and personality before
they are one in purpose in mind in
character but not in person it is thus
that God and Christ are one
yet here there are cross purposes
but also
false gospel false gospel false gospel
Jesus's blood and obedience to the law
one can have favor with God
that is not what the Bible teaches about
how one has favor with God
nope
obedience does not earn you favor
Christ does and it's not well Christ yet
right right it's by the merits of Christ
that we're able to do such such that our
works can be found pleasing no no no no
no no no no you're not getting it
Solace Christus
the Adventist Church loves to say we're
attached to the Protestant reformers
we're we're part of the Protestant
Reformation
we affirmed the five Solas they gave a
series we're going to review these at
some point on the channel Ty Gibson
he preached on the five solos oh my
goodness it's just like no you're just
doing you're just trying to make it
appear as though you guys don't believe
Solus Christus this shows it right here
it means that Christ Alone is how we are
saved
obedience is something that comes after
being reconciled being in Christ
adopted into his family
well actually in fact no perfect
obedience does reconcile you to God the
difference is it's Christ's perfect
obedience
it's Christ's obedience
the Christian's obedience is a fruit of
already being reconciled and covered in
Christ
strictly on Christ when I stand before
God
I'm going to say in Christ and In Christ
Alone
no matter what any of my efforts were My
Eyes Are Fixed On the Lord Jesus nothing
that I've done nothing that I've said no
sort of obedience can ever add anything
to the perfect finished work of Jesus
Christ
and I'm not one of these Lawless I'm not
advocating that you guys can keep
false you know bearing false witness and
claiming that I'm part I'm not part of
that and the majority of Christians are
not by the way
that is a fringe minority of people
not man when I talk to people at my
church none of no people at my church
think that way they have a hunger and a
desire to serve the Lord a hunger and a
desire to grow they're warring with
their sin Etc and yet none of us are
going to stand before God ever
and say
anything about ourselves
that's not how you get favor with God
and again it doesn't automatically then
mean oh so you're saying people can just
live however they want it's this false
dichotomy of extremes no I'm not saying
either of those things I'm saying
they're both wrong I'm saying that
obedience is the fruit of having been
reconciled because a fallen dead lost
sinner has no desire to seek God
the fact that a person even has that
desire evidences that God is at work
and he's the author and finisher of our
faith he's going to continue sanctifying
but in Adventist theology it's you have
to get to a certain Sanctified State
through the imparted great well I'm
getting ahead of myself here we're going
to look at that a little bit more
um later
but that's a false gospel folks they do
not understand the law gospel
distinction another reason why they
should stop claiming to be attached to
the Protestant reformers because the law
gospel distinction is like
refer Protestant Reformation 101
along with solo scriptura the other
thing they redefine
uh Jesus bathed the Heavenly Host be
reconciled to the plan that his father
accepted
just a minute sorry my notes Here
got a little bit thrown off
what number is this
sorry folks my notes are getting a
little crazy here
she says Jesus bathed the Heavenly Host
be reconciled to the plan that his
father accepted and rejoiced that that
Fallen man could be exalted again
through his death to obtain favor with
God and enjoy Heaven Again saying that
same thing no
no the father did not accept a plan that
Jesus presented to him
as if the father is
it's just
it's not possible it's not possible
folks
testimonies for the church Volume 8 page
268 God is the father of Christ
is the son of God
to Christ has been
given in exalted position
he has been made equal with the father
all the councils of God are open to his
son
to Christ has been given
in exalted position meaning he didn't
have it before
they love to point to well in Patriarchs
and Prophets on page 34 she says that it
was not a change in this position yeah
she's all over the place that should
send up red flags it shouldn't cause you
to think okay well how can I defend her
very clearly to Christ has been given in
exalted position
he has been made equal with the father
so unbelievably blasphemous
Jesus is eternally equal with both the
father and the spirit
this is why that when they claim to be
trinitarians it is all lip service
lip service
the one Lord God Almighty is the father
son and spirit they are the one true God
co-equal co-eternal no division no
monarchianism no subordinationism
and you're probably thinking
he's not the Lord God Almighty where are
you getting that from okay
lots of places maybe we'll dedicate a
stream specifically to all of these
because there are a bunch but let's walk
through a couple of them here how's that
sound folks
First Kings 8 39.
First Kings eight
39.
and let's look at a couple things that
we are told about
the Lord
then here in heaven you're Dwelling
Place in forgive and act and render to
each whose heart you know talking about
God God knows the heart
according to all his ways for you you
only know the hearts of all the children
of mankind
so audience who alone knows the thoughts
of the hearts of men
God
okay
well we already saw something earlier
where Jesus talking to the disciples
they said you can see the hearts of men
but let's continue on this
Psalm 44 21.
would not God discover this for he knows
the secrets of the heart
again God knows that the secrets of the
heart psalm 103.
oh sorry we gotta switch over here
Psalm 103 2-3
bless the Lord O my soul and forget not
all his benefits who forgives all your
iniquity and heals all your diseases
so the Lord that word Lord there that's
translated the word translated Lord
there is Yahweh
the Lord can see the hearts of men knows
the secrets of the heart
forgives iniquities which ascends and is
able to heal all of your diseases
this is something God God does
now let's look at Mark 2 5-10
Mark 2 5-10
and when Jesus saw their faith he said
to the paralytic son your sins are
forgiven
now some of the scribes were sitting
there questioning in their hearts
why does this man speak like that he's
blaspheming who can forgive sins but God
Alone
the scribes knew that
knew the Old Testament or at least they
thought they did they knew it enough to
know that only God can do that but
notice what it said that was them
questioning in their hearts they didn't
say that out loud
and immediately perceiving in his spirit
that they thus questioned within
themselves said to them why do you
question these things in your hearts
which is easier to say to the paralytic
your sins are forgiven or to say rise
take up your bed and walk
but that you may know that the son of
man has Authority on Earth to forgive
sins he said to the paralytic
when people tell you these things like
Jesus never said he's God where does the
bible say I where did Jesus ever say I
am God like Muslims use
folks it is all over if you know your
Old Testament
you read these things man just in mark
one through two alone there's like nine
instances where Jesus is just going or
any forgiven sins healing people doing
all these things that's why they're
pissed off at him all the time
but notice what it said it said
immediately in his spirit
he knew what they were what they were
thinking within themselves
there's an important thing here folks
in scripture when you hear the authors
referring to Jesus and saying in his
spirit it's referring to his divine
nature
when you hear terms like according to
the flesh
like in Romans 1 3 Romans 9 5
that according to his flesh it's talking
about his human nature
those are the places where the church
was getting the understanding around
what scripture is saying about Christ
having two Natures Divine and human this
also poses a major problem by the way
for the Adventist Church that thinks man
is really nothing more than a bag of
meat
but the point being is that Jesus Christ
is the Lord God Almighty the Lord God
Almighty alone can forgive sins heal
diseases and can see the inner thoughts
and and
doings of a man internally so that's
just one of many of those examples like
I said in the The Book of Mark alone we
have
the first two chapters there's like a
ton of them
but again this idea that Jesus was made
equal with the father no Hebrews 13 8
Jesus is the same today yesterday
forever he is immutable he was not
exalted to be made equal with the father
this is Blasphemous heresy
the father is the fullness of the
godhead bodily and is invisible to
Mortal sight
multiple places faith I live by Page 39
evangelism page 614.
this is just outright false nowhere does
the scripture say that the the father is
the fullness of the godhead bodily Jesus
is the fullness of the godhead bodily
Colossians 2 9.
Jesus is not the father
this is like a modalist type statement
like well was the father that was
incarnated inside the sun and it was the
father's spear all these crazy things
that the unitarians and and Oneness
modulus try and come up with
the Bible just does not say this the
Bible does not say that the father is
the fullness that God had bodily she
never wrote a single sentence of heresy
folks
doesn't retract a single sentence that
she's written barricaded by a thus saith
the Lord you go against it you're going
against the spirit of God
crazy
now this one's nuts folks
I've been searching for this for quite
some time because I couldn't remember
the wording exactly
I brought this up when I was in SDA
University to one of my professors and
it caused me to be reprimanded afterward
seriously and I was not causing a
disturbance I was like one year into
being born again and we had to redesire
of Ages for this class that I was in
and we got to this chapter and I thought
to myself huh
that's odd that doesn't seem to fit with
the text
more on that in a second let's read it a
little bit long she says
quote Jesus refused to receive the
homage of his people until he had the
assurance that his sacrifice was
accepted by the father
he ascended to the Heavenly courts this
is talking about right after the
resurrection like literally immediately
after the resurrection he walks out of
the Tomb
he ascended to the Heavenly courts and
from God himself heard the assurance
that his atonement for the sins of men
had been ample
that through his blood all might gain
eternal life the father ratified the
covenant made with Christ that he would
receive repentant and obedient men and
would love them even as he loves his son
Christ was to complete his work and
fulfill his pledge to make a man more
precious than Feingold even man uh
even a man then the golden wedge of
ophir Isaiah 13 12. all power in heaven
on Earth was given to the Prince of Life
and he returned to his followers in a
world of sin that he might impart to
them
of his glory or of his power and Glory
so you know what that means folks
that would mean that the Adventists are
teaching by way of Ellen White
a third coming not the second coming
this was the second coming
Jesus came in the Incarnation was born
died buried resurrected ascended to
Heaven had to find out from the father
that his sacrifice was accepted again
doesn't have this information
finds out that it was returns to earth
is here for 40 days and then ascends
again and then he's going to come back
again
but furthermore this contradicts
Revelation 1 or Romans 1 4.
Romans 1 4 says that Jesus was declared
to be the Son of God with power by his
resurrection from the dead if Jesus had
remained in the Tomb it would have meant
that he didn't die for our sins he died
for his own
but the fact that God raised him from
the dead proved that his sacrifice was
acceptable
if he would have remained in the Tomb
that would have been the sign that it
wasn't accepted the fact that he was
resurrected not just that but the fact
that he himself in John 2 and John 10
said indefinitely Or rather uh
definitely he would resurrect himself
there's no question about it
no that's just crazy Jesus did not have
a secret Ascension to heaven
and then come back
Etc the parallel quote to this by the
way is in story of redemption by Ellen
White as you see there page 235 where
she actually quotes in in that quote of
this uh John 2017. so that's what
Adventists are going to quote
the SDA Bible commentary has this on
this verse where he says touch me not
for I'm not yet ascended to my father
but go to my brethren and say unto them
I ascended unto my father and your
father
um or I Ascend unto my father and your
father and to my God and your God
so this is his response to Mary so this
is what Ellen infuses in to say see he
was telling her that he hadn't ascended
yet and he had to go to ascend before he
could receive homage to find out if his
sacrifice was accepted then when he came
back then he would receive the homage no
that's not at all what's being said
there
Jesus is not saying he's about to ascend
to the father quickly to then come back
for 40 days and Ascend again he tells
Mary not to cling to her
the Greek word that's translated for
cling in its most literal sense means to
hold on to and keep in place like to
hold down
Mary was so zooted and hyped
to see Jesus she didn't want to let him
go
and he was simply telling her not to
hold him down because he had somewhere
to be he had to be seen by the
eyewitnesses the disciples Etc and then
Ascend to heaven to take his rightful
Throne upon resurrecting he couldn't
remain with them nothing to do with the
secret Ascension to find out if he's if
his sacrifice was even accepted
this is again where these inspired
details are just filling in the gaps for
us supposedly
another quote Christ in his Sanctuary
page 153
those who are living upon the Earth when
the intercession of Christ shall cease
in the sanctuary above are to stand in
the sight of a holy God without a
mediator
their robes must be spotless their
characters must be purified from sin by
the blood of sprinkling through the
grace of God and their own diligent
effort
they must be conquerors in the battle
with evil while the investigative
judgment is going forward in heaven
while the sins of penitent Believers are
being removed from the sanctuary there's
to be a special work of purification of
putting away of sin among God's people
upon the Earth this work is more clearly
presented in the messages of Revelation
14. uh no
Hebrews makes it clear Jesus forever
lives to make intercession for his
people Hebrews 7 25 Adventists sadly do
not understand that Jesus will forever
be the mediator between God and man even
into eternity
they see this as a oh it's just only
something that's having to be done when
sin is an issue no folks our Eternal
bridge to God forever keeping us never
losing us is Jesus forever that's what
it means when it says he always he
forever lives to make intercession for
us
they have him in a temporary role trying
to get enough people to a sinlessly
perfect state so he can then transition
to a different role during what Ellen
calls the courtroom scene which you can
look up in Christ in his sanctuary
another quote when the work of
Investigation shall be ended when the
cases of those who in all ages have
professed to be followers of Christ have
been examined and decided then and not
till then probation will close and the
door of Mercy will be shut so this was
again one of the new pivots because the
door of Mercy shut back at the shut door
but then well no another door opened in
the most holy place and so probation
will go until that door shuts
thus in the one short sentence
they that were ready went in with him to
the marriage and the door was shut
they love the parable of the bridegroom
on on that which is funny because she
initially was quoting that to support
the shut door
and then now it's well it is about the
shut door but the new door that opened
being shut later
God is a horrible Communicator
apparently
we are carried down through the savior's
final Administration to the time when
the great work for man's salvation shall
be completed
and
it's only after the work of the
investigative judgment that man's
salvation is a is accomplished
[Music]
no Hebrews 9 12 says Jesus secured our
Eternal Redemption already at the cross
as we saw earlier and in his
resurrection which is evidenced by his
entering into heaven itself to sit on
his throne and ruin Reign until all of
his enemies are made a footstool
he's not up there still working on
Redemption
Adventists give this stuff up and rest
and trust in Jesus Christ and the
finished work that he's done it doesn't
mean Jesus is sitting up there twiddling
his thumbs
you just need to rightly understand the
high Priestly and kingly role of Christ
we cover that on this channel if you
haven't seen it go check it out with
Anthony Rogers
again Christ in his Sanctuary page 182.
at the time appointed for the Judgment
the close of the 2300 days in 1844 began
the work of investigation and blotting
out of sins all who have ever taken upon
themselves the name of Christ must pass
its searching scrutiny both the living
and the dead are to be judged out of
those things which are written in the
books according to their works
nope Jesus already put sin Away by the
sacrifice of himself at the cross
furthermore
um Jesus isn't dealing with sin anymore
like we said Hebrews 9 24
he's not standing like the levitical
aaronic priest the author goes to Great
lines folks in Hebrews 7-10 just read it
through he goes through Great Lengths to
explain this drastic difference
him being seated is a huge deal
huge deal
but not just that the blotting out of
sins did not begin in 1844. tell that to
the psalmist
we're actually going to look at that
here in in a moment
this is signs of the times July 31st
1901.
for the highest good of his creatures
God has given a perfect law a law that
demands perfect obedience God compels no
one to obey this law he leaves men free
to decide whether they will obey and
receive the reward of obedience or
disobey and receive the punishment of
transgression uh no the Bible does not
teach that perfect obedience to God's
law rewards you with eternal life
again obedience is a fruit of already
having said eternal life
a perfect evidence that Ellen White had
no concept of the law gospel distinction
like I mentioned earlier
we are saved by the gospel not the law
that isn't the proper use of the law
that she's saying here obedience to God
is the fruit of having already received
eternal life and the gift of Salvation
the holy spirit is given as the seal and
down payment of our inheritance
you aren't rewarded for salvation by
your obedience to the law
and then Adventists will balk and scoff
at people claiming that they teach a
workspace system no one who teaches a
workspace system says we teach a
workspace system they all say no no no
we only believe it's by Jesus no you
don't you believe Jesus made the way
possible and now through the help of the
Holy Spirit if you're truly saved
you'll be on that path and you'll get
Sanctified to a part where to a point
where you'll no longer need the imparted
righteousness of Christ to you because
you'll eventually be so Sanctified to a
point where when the time of trouble
comes and you have to stand before God
without an intercessor you'll be able to
stand because you're sinlessly perfect
but furthermore
Ellen White had zero concept
of the active and passive Obedience of
Christ which is imputed to the believer
both are essential parts of Christ's
work on Earth and both are needed if we
are to have any hope of salvation
we are saved by Perfect obedience but
it's the perfect Obedience of Jesus
so you might be asking I've never heard
these terms what is active and passive
obedience
Jesus's active obedience is his perfect
obedience to God's law
Jesus's passive obedience
is his paying the penalty for our
failure to obey God's law
again Jesus is active obedience is his
perfect obedience to the law of God
his passive obedience
is paying the penalty for our failure to
obey God's law
his passive obedience is paying the
penalty for breaking the law
culminates on the cross but was not only
restricted to their
so think of like the daily
minute-by-minute suffering that Christ
experienced as he was immersed in 33
years of a sin-stained creation that was
in constant Rebellion against the fall
every thought word deed motive every
single second of the day
that's what the standard is folks
perfect Holiness is loving God perfectly
with every thought word deed and motive
it's not simply the letter of the Ten
Commandments
Jesus loved God perfectly with every
thought word deed and motive at every
single second
that's his passive obedience or sorry
sorry his act of obedience
his active obedience
so I was passive before his act of
obedience is his perfect obedience to
the father's will
which it didn't end once he arrived at
Gethsemane
his obedience to his father not my will
but yours
carried him into Gethsemane and Beyond
his death on the cross itself is an
example of his active as well as passive
obedience and that satisfied the
righteous requirements of God's law
God's law makes demands of us and if one
fails to meet those demands which we all
do yes Adventists including you
if you understand how high the standard
is
then what comes with that is a penalty
which is death
so it's a it's that double demand of
God's law that makes Christ active and
passive obedience necessary
he both fulfills the Law's demands and
pays its penalty
he perfectly obeyed his father's law as
our previous as a perfect representative
in comparison to Adam who failed and as
our new representative the second Adam
we were talking about headship the other
night this is that same concept here
the second Adam Jesus Took the penalty
prescribed by God's law for our
disobedience if he hadn't done both we'd
still be under condemnation
but because he did do both we can
joyously claim
like Paul did in Romans 1 or Romans 8 1.
there is therefore now no condemnation
for those who are
in Christ Jesus we talked about that
phrase too the salvific term
a person is given a foreign alien
righteousness Philippians 3 9-10
completely not imparted in small parts
over time to get you to a point in this
Progressive progress sanctification is
Progressive but it's not like the
Adventist Church teaches
you are given the active and passive
Obedience of Christ imputed on your
behalf
that's how you're able to stand
perfectly righteous right now this is
what Luther called uh simultaneously a
saint and Sinner and we're going to talk
about that in some coming months as well
I'm trying to get some Lutheran guys on
here to uh help us talk about that a
little bit but in the Adventist system
there's going to be much condemnation
for those who are supposedly in Christ
because you can be in Christ and not
have a good enough obedience to the law
which will then eventually condemn you
so they'll point to no no Ellen said
that he came to free us from the
condemnation of the law right to make
that possible but lots of people in the
investigative judgment
are going to then be booted
and the law will condemn them
so yes perfect obedience is necessary
for salvation but it's the perfect
Obedience of Jesus not mine
the idea that Jesus made it possible for
your obedience to be found acceptable
such that you can get to a perfect state
of perfect obedience and then can be
found worthy that's not the gospel that
is not the gospel folks Adventists
you're never going to make it
and that's not me saying so just go up
and live however you want
the Romans 7 which we're going to talk
about here momentarily the Romans 7
experience is a real experience that
true Christians experience throughout
their whole life until your Fallen
fleshly body is sown a perishable seed
it will not be raised in Incorruptible
seed it's not Satan that makes you sin
it is your flesh it is you acting upon
your flesh and until your Fallen flesh
sees death and or is transformed and
you're put into a glorified State you
will not you will continue warring with
sin
but this gets into the nature of man and
the falsity that they have around that
but
next quote here I know it's getting late
folks
selected messages book one page 341
Satan's position in heaven had been next
to the son of God
he was first among the angels
Patriarchs and Prophets page 35 there
was one who perverted the freedom of God
had the freedom that God had granted to
his creatures sin originated with him
who next to Christ had been most honored
of God and was highest in power and
Glory among the inhabitants of Heaven
nowhere does the Bible say this
it's wild how much Ellen White talked
about Satan and how much sdas think they
know about Satan talking about his
thoughts things he supposedly said
before the creation of Earth the Bible
has very little to say about Satan folks
yet the Adventist Church thinks they
know all about him
and only someone demonized would say
something like Satan was next to the Son
of God who is Yahweh the Almighty
what a just seriously what a Blasphemous
statement and she said this over and
over and over again
it's a core to the great controversy
this is what started this whole great
controversy supposedly
Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the Father which triggered Lucifer
starting to get prideful and become
jealous
they can bark and scoff at that all they
want and say no no no no no
that is what started it
blasphemous
now here here we get an insight into
what the Adventist teaching is of
Resurrection which isn't really
Resurrection this is again them
borrowing terminology but not defining
it the correct way
this is from Ellen White's book Heaven
on page 40 but also it's in the SDA
Bible commentary on volume six
um page 1092 and 93 quote
our personal identity is preserved in
the resurrection though not the same
particles of matter or material
substance as went into the grave
the wondrous works of God are a mystery
of man the spirit the character of man
so your spirit is your character your
personality
is return to God there to be preserved
well how does that work
this is why I often say Adventists
believe that when you die they believe
in Soul death your soul is a combination
of your breath and your body when you
die your breath goes back to God who
gave it your body goes into the ground
you essentially cease to exist your soul
is no longer a a thing anymore because
the two have become separated
but your breath's not animate so it just
exits and goes back to God
you're remained or you remain in his
memory
that's how you remain
the spirit the character of man is
returned to God there to be preserved
it's preserved in his mind
in the resurrection every man will have
his own character
God in his own time will call forth the
dead giving again the breath of life and
bidding the dry bones live the same form
will come forth but it will be free from
disease and every defect
it lives again bearing the same
individuality of features so that friend
will recognize
our friend will recognize friend
there is no law of God in nature which
shows that God gives back the same
identical particles of matter which
compose the body before death God shall
give the righteous dead a body that will
please him close quote
no this is not a resurrection and
contradicts what the Bible says think
about this
Jesus did not have a new body made of
new particles
he resurrected in the same body he died
in and we will be the same
First Corinthians 15 Paul goes to Great
Lengths talking about the resurrection
Jesus bore the crucifixion marks of his
same body upon resurrecting John 20
24-25 it was the same body he died in
but was glorified
he was not given a new body composed of
completely new particles otherwise his
old body would have been in the Tomb
it's only been three days it wouldn't
have completely decayed and disappeared
if this is the case Jesus did not
resurrect and then had new particles
that formed a different body and his old
body was back in the Tomb
is this twisting the Biblical teaching
of Resurrection folks and it's all
Downstream of this whole system and
narrative they have to have it being
this way this is why they don't
understand the new creation either
they don't understand they think it's
going to be this completely different
thing that's all after the millennial
Reign it's already started now Jesus is
already making all things new we're new
creatures in Christ second Corinthians 5
16 and 17. it's not just pithy language
you say oh it's a behavioral
modification no the behavioral
modification is a fruit of being a new
creature in Christ
what I'm awaiting now is my glorif the
glorification of my body my inner man
has been raised to spiritual newness of
life and that will carry over with me
into the consummation of the the
fullness of the new creation being here
but it's already started
you're not going to be given a new body
of new particles with your personality
from the memory of God poured it back
into a different body such that oh you
can be recognized because your
personality is the same
no Jesus is our example on this and Paul
goes to Great Lengths again read First
Corinthians 15 he did not get a brand
new body with new particles
Christ in this Sanctuary page 177.
all who have truly repented of sin and
by faith claim the blood of Christ as
their atoning sacrifice have had pardon
entered against their names in the books
of Heaven as they have become partakers
of the righteousness of Christ and their
characters are found to be in harmony
with the law of God their sins will be
blotted out like we looked at earlier
and they themselves will be accounted
worthy of eternal life
so much heresy so little time
notice like I was mentioning earlier
Christ's righteousness is gradually
given overtime in small spurts based on
your law keeping
to eventually arrive at a place where
you have a righteousness that mirrors
Jesus's that's what the SDA Church means
when they say the righteousness of
Christ they do not mean like I said what
pulse mentions in Philippians 3 9-10 or
what Protestants teach
that you are given an alien foreign
righteousness that is wholly sufficient
the active and passive obedience but
that gradually over time based on your
law keeping Christ gives you some of his
righteousness to make up where you fall
short and gradually imparts to you his
character in the same fashion
Christ is simply a conduit in their
system to get you to a place that you
can be found worthy it's at that point
that your sins will be blotted out and
you'll be awarded with eternal life
so never mind Isaiah God himself
speaking in Isaiah 44 24 I've blotted
out your transgressions like a cloud and
your sins like Mist return to me for I
have redeemed you no no no he didn't
begin blotting out any sins until 1844.
but furthermore Jesus and John both
Proclaim that Believers can know that
they have present tense
eternal life right now
when you don't understand the true
nature of man and you think that you're
just a bag of protoplasm with uh or a
meat bag
with a breath
you're not going to understand how like
I just mentioned earlier
the new man within me that's warring
with the old man my flesh
or like Jesus according to the flesh
according to his spirit
you're not going to be able to to grasp
this
but yes sins have been blotted out
already before folks
he said it right there Isaiah 44 24.
and Jesus and John Clearly say you can
know that you have eternal life right
now not after some investigative
judgment period to see if you're worthy
at the end of his first epistle my
pastor just preached on this last Lord's
Day
John States I write these things to you
who believe in the name of the son of
God that you may know that you have
eternal life
first John 5.
Jesus himself says John 5 truly truly I
say to you whoever hears my word
this is just like we were reading before
with with Paul talking about the seal
those who heard the word of of Truth The
Gospel of your salvation were given the
Holy Spirit as a down payment of your
salvation you heard the message believed
you received the Holy Spirit and you
received eternal life and that's the
down payment of it
truly truly I say to you whoever hears
my word believes him who sent me has
present tense eternal life he does not
come into judgment but is passed from
Death To Life
this is in the context of judgment for
condemnation or justification read the
passage John 5 Jesus says all authority
to judge has been given to me again a
statement of his equality with God
and this is in the context of
condemnation or justification Jesus says
those who believe
do not come into judgment for
condemnation because they've already
passed from Death to life I've already
been adopted into God's family I've
already been transferred from the
kingdom of darkness into the Kingdom of
Light
our judgment already took place two
thousand years ago at Calvary in the
person of Jesus Christ
the representative who paid our Ransom
in full such that he can grant eternal
life to those he freely bestows it upon
so those that believe in the name of the
son of God and believe the father who
sent him ultimately getting at a
heartfelt trust and belief not simply
checking a mental box I'm not saying oh
I went down the aisle said of sinner's
prayer and got my ticket punched for
heaven that's not what I'm saying I'm
talking about a heartfelt when God moves
Upon A spiritually dead person
regenerates them they're a new creature
in Christ
when that happens a person has eternal
life and God is the author and finisher
of our salvation
we have eternal life presently praise
God I thank God for that every single
day
getting close to the end here just a
couple more Christ in this Sanctuary
page 57. as in the final atonement the
sins of the truly penitent are to be
blotted from the records of Heaven no
more to be remembered or come into mind
so in the type they were born away Into
the Wilderness forever separated from
the congregation she's talking about the
day of atonement here in Leviticus 16.
since Satan is the originator of sin the
direct instigator of all the sins that
caused the death of the Son of God
Justice demands that Satan shall suffer
the final punishment
Christ's work for the Redemption of men
and the purification of the Universe
from sin will be closed again he's still
working on Redemption
by the removal of Sin from the Heavenly
sanctuary and the placing of these sins
upon Satan who will bear the final
penalty
no Satan is not the final sin Bearer
that takes sins away this is Blasphemous
false and wrong
nothing in Leviticus 16 Adventists says
anything about the scapegoat
representing responsibility yet this
entire Theory hinges upon that nothing
zip nada nothing in the text about
responsibility and the scapegoat that's
cut whole cloth from Ellen White
the scapegoat functioned as expiation
not responsibility expiation means the
removal or taking away a single goat
could not do this which is why two were
necessary for a singular sin offering
Leviticus 16 5-6
one paid the penalty for sin by being
killed the other carried the sins away a
dead goat couldn't do both
or it couldn't do it couldn't carry sins
away
but Jesus can
Jesus is all of the Law's offerings and
sacrifices in one not just the Lord's
goat and the scapegoat
he's the burnt offering the sin offering
of which the scapegoat was apart the
guilt offering the Free Will offering
Etc
he's every single sacrifice and offering
in one because he's far superior to an
animal
all of those sacrifices were pointing to
Jesus
this is why I always tell them folks you
are ascribing a part of Christ's work of
accomplishing all of the law
the law required these sacrifices and
offerings
Jesus fulfills all of them you are
taking one aspect of the Law's offerings
and sacrifice requirements and ascribing
it to Satan
a part of Jesus's work
no no
Jesus is all and we're going to do a
stream on that hopefully at some point
um to show that Jesus is the burn
offering the sin offering the guilt
offering the free wall he's all of them
Adventist again I challenge you
show us where Leviticus 16 says anything
about the scapegoat representing
responsibility for sin
but furthermore Ellen White would even
go on
to later admit
some apply the solemn type the scapegoat
to Satan this is not correct
he cannot bear his own sins at the
choosing of Barabbas pilate washed his
hands he cannot be represented as the
scapegoat the awful cry uttered with a
hasty awful recklessness by the Satan
inspired multitude swelling louder and
louder reaches up to the throne of God
his blood be upon us and upon our
children Matthew 27 25. Christ was the
scapegoat which the type represents he
alone can be represented by the goat
Born Into the Wilderness he alone over
whom death had not power was able to
Bear our sins
letters and manuscripts volume 112 1897.
so years later Ellen White completely
contradicts herself and no before you
try and use the this was never published
argument we already saw what she said
regarding her writings
she didn't make any distinguished
between only those that are published or
from God it's all of God or all of Satan
whatever contradicts God's word we can
be sure proceeds from Satan
so folks I know that was a lot
we're going on three hours here
Adventists you have to get honest about
these things
there is no getting around being
Adventist but not accepting the writings
of Ellen G white being what she claimed
them to be the Adventist Church upholds
them as such
the Adventist Church upholds them as
such
the statement of confidence in her
writings
fundamental belief number 18
you reject that you reject them being
the remnant Church she's the identifying
Mark of the remnant Church specifically
the prophetic gifting
and if you didn't see what she said at
the beginning go back and look at her
own statements
she fails this test beyond a shadow of a
doubt
beyond a shadow of a doubt
so with that said
let's lower her into the ground shall we
let's take a moment here as uh the
funeral procession March
takes place
[Music]
all right folks I hope you enjoyed the
stream tonight I hope you guys found it
beneficial we ended at about three hours
exactly here that was about an hour per
section
it's what I kind of anticipated told you
guys was going to be a mega stream but
it needed done it needed done we'll
probably do another one of these at some
point because
um like I said we we only scratched the
surface this was only a
the tip of the iceberg it was the tip of
the iceberg and we had some fun
obviously tonight a little bit of a
themed thing going on here
um but
this is serious folks
you need to get honest about this it's
time to get honest about this
go where the truth leads
we all had to come to this Crossroad
we don't hate Adventists farmer
Adventists some probably do but I'm
telling you I talk with tons of former
Adventists they don't hate you guys we
don't hate you guys
we want you to come to know the truth
the Adventist Church is lying to you
they are lying to you
believe it or not they are lying to you
they don't want you to see these things
they don't want to deal with these
things it doesn't matter the way it's
presented it doesn't matter who's saying
it
people often say oh man you're so
aggressive you have an angry Spirit you
must be well no people have different
personality types and people are have
different callings and God uses those
types of things
it but it doesn't matter who's saying it
or how they say it Steve Daly is one of
the nicest guys calm collected scholarly
they say the same thing about him
Alberto Tim's response to Steve Daly
didn't deal with anything Steve Daly
said in his book in terms of the
substance it all dealt with well the way
that you said this is not the right way
you're
deal with the substance man they know
these things exist they don't want to
talk about it they've got too much
invested in this
at this point to admit these things the
whole house of cards topples over
they're not telling you about these
things when I was in Adventist schools
we were taught the first second vision
of Ellen White they corrected her they
didn't cement error in baloney we just
looked at it
go read the whole thing you tell me if
I'm taking it out of context
it's time to get serious about these
things folks it's time to get serious
about these things
thanks for being here tonight
we'll catch you guys around next time as
always like I've been telling you and
I'll continue to say Adventists tell us
come out of for my people we say the
same thing back
come out of her
my people God bless
[Music]